[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it is finally time now listen
from tom brady's on retirement shocking
trades of russell wilson tyree kill we
got a new quarterback in cleveland we
have a new team name in washington it is
only fitting that one of the wildest
offseasons in a long time culminates
with one of the most unpredictable nfl
drafts that i can ever remember and let
me tell you something first of all my
name is adam lefkow and i am hosting the
draft here at bleach report for the
ninth straight year which is crazy i
can't remember a draft where we're
sitting here and i don't know who's
being taken to my left
the lead br nfl draft analyst the dapper
the suave man the hair looks great
connor rogers in the house how you
feeling thank you sir feeling great man
this is the most exciting draft that
i've ever covered just because it's so
unpredictable when you look at it from
the fact that we don't know for sure
who's going number one overall and the
domino effect that's going to have on
the picks following i love it to your
left the grand return
the in the bleachers not just a college
football analyst but a true truth
when it comes to everything football
michael forget the first name felder
there we go welcome back dad thank you
guys i'm glad you listen when i got the
email i thought it was a joke
and uh but i'm happy to be back happy to
be kicking it with you guys i mean we've
done this together before so this is
yeah we've got other folks that are
going to pop in but this is this is
three guys talking a little ball and
that's what i love about you is you're
really good at helping us transition
it's not just us three we have three
dudes that are not just guys they're
superstars let's put them on the screen
now first of all we have breaking down
the trenches in the middle repping his
school pride
a perennial pro bowler center for the
eagles jason kelsey oh yeah touching his
shirt what a legend
uh to his right your left just
dissecting the defensive backs one of
the greatest to ever do it all decade
cornerback richard sherman and on the
right working the wide outs he's going
to have a busy night tonight because a
lot of wide receivers are getting taken
young stud for the lions 90 catches in
his rookie year ahmanra
saint brown ready to go we're going to
talk to them in a second we just wanted
to show your faces so you could go oh
wow this draft show is going to be
amazing which it is so we're going to
talk to them in a second i want to talk
to you though about what you're getting
here with draft night on bleach report
if you've watched this before you know
how we roll if you're new let me tell
you we don't do commercials
when someone gets drafted
15 minutes later we don't go let's take
another look at that we're not worried
about interviews we're not worried about
feature stories we want you to get your
draft information when your team picks
and that's all we care about that's the
main thing
as soon as it breaks on twitter we're
not waiting for television we are going
to give you that pick immediately
because that's the world that we live in
okay that's how we do it here on draft
night uh and we're breaking it down now
we're getting ready for the number one
pick
i wanna start here with you guys and
then we're gonna go to our esteemed
guest
connor your prediction for the number
one pick
and how have they kept it so secret for
so long the jacksonville jaguars the
truth is lefko they haven't decided now
they know now as we sit here but it
really came down to the wire came down
in the final week which is nearly
unheard of for a number one pick in the
draft and that's because there's a
difference of opinion and that's going
to be the theme you're going to hear
tonight with a lot of the top picks i
think in jacksonville it's no secret
trent balki a guy that's willing to take
risk in the draft right he loves trayvon
walker a projection pick out of georgia
a guy that only had six sacks this year
has never had a massive productive
season but his big is athletic there's
versatility there now you have an owner
that obviously reads a lot of headlines
and is probably sitting there saying why
aren't we taking aiden hutchinson and
you have a coach that a couple people
are part of this show are very familiar
with yeah that is an offensive super
bowl winning coach and you had the first
pick of the draft last year and you have
a quarterback and you watched the film
of last year the situation he's walking
into and probably looks at plenty of
holes on that offense so there's been
divide left go but at the end of the day
if the gm is the guy in control and has
the power and that's trent balke it
looks like it's going to be trayvon
walker who would your pick be
this is the crazy part my pick
personally would be kayvon thibaut i
love him i think he's explosive i think
he's the best pass rusher in this draft
uh the pick i think they should make is
one of two guys it's either evan neil or
it is aiden hutchinson if you're going
defense you're a team that's had a ton
of turmoil a team that's had a ton of
turnover a team that's that craves
stability consistency both of the
consistency both of those guys offer
that and
right now you're stepping into the
shadows you're stepping into the unknown
with trayvon walker because you're not
sure what you're going to get out of him
that doesn't mean he's going to be bad
right he's going to be a solid nfl
football player he's going to be very
good but he is the lesser known of the
other quantities at the pass rushing
spot
now let's bring in
the big ballers let's go to richard
sherman first richard i'm curious who
would your pick be uh for number one
overall and what do you think of maybe a
guy that doesn't have as much of a track
record
i i i'm not a fan i'm not a fan of it
you know i hate when when people project
you know i i hate the word potential you
know and i you're going to hear it a
gazillion times tonight but
put it on put the tape on show me
production then i can justify drafting a
guy like aiden hutchinson is it should
be the surefire if you're not going
there then you need to protect trevor
lawrence obviously they extended cam
robinson but you need bookends you know
that they got a lot of holes on that
offense and that's where you need to
pick first but if you're going defense i
think you go with a more sure fire pick
in aiden hutcherson all right let's go
to the guy that anytime an offensive
lineman defensive lineman is going to be
picked in the trenches our jason kelsey
will help us break it down and i know
that he studied all the defensive
linemen and all of the offensive linemen
when you hear trayvon walker could be
the pick what do you think
well you know he's obviously not the
safe pick the safe pick would be aiden
hutchinson or evan neal out of alabama
those are probably the two more polish
guys but
when you look at the pick you you look
at their defensive coordinator caldwell
who was in tampa bay they like to mix it
up do a lot of different fronts
multiplicity of pressures
uh you start to understand a little bit
why they would go this route you know
trayvon's a guy that moved all over the
place at georgia he played inside he
plays outside uh the way a lot of teams
are starting to rush the passer now is
build these five-man fronts with these
outside linebacker defensive end types
and he fits that mold really well
now he does i mean this is a projection
pick he's clearly not as polished of a
rusher as some of these other guys in
particular you know thibodeaux and
hutchinson right uh you know but when
you look at the measurables
i mean the guys
lights it up and with where he plays and
kind of what he did at georgia yeah uh
it could be a good scheme fit down in
jacksonville all right very interesting
here it is interesting to note yes they
took trevor lawrence with the first pick
of the draft last year their two first
round picks in the years before were
both pass rushers as well caleb chaisan
and josh allen all of this being said i
want to bring in amman ross saint brown
because the lions have the second pick
and so if everyone's talking about oh
they're going to reach for the first
pick
i mean oman what are you thinking like
second pick who do you hope falls to you
guys at pick number two
you know that's a tough question um i
think aiden hutchinson if he does fall
to number two it just seems right to me
uh he went to michigan his family's from
out here
for him to play for his home team in
detroit i think it just fits well it
sounds right for everyone
and i think i mean you watch his ted you
put on his tape his motor i think is
what stands out most to me when i watch
it um you know i don't know too much
about d-line o-line play but i can tell
when someone has a motor and he really
has that that crazy motor never stops
rushing the pasture so
i think aidan hutched into the lines
just it just sounds right it does i mean
i i believe he was lived 15 minutes for
the practice facility so that would be
pretty awesome guys thank you so much
we'll be getting to you guys shortly
you're already getting buzz mr connor
rogers what are you hearing yeah what
interests me right now is the number one
pick say it is trayvon walker right and
there once again there are a lot of
names in play here number two becomes
fascinating because you look at it it's
been assumed that aiden hutchinson would
be the pick here over and over again and
i've heard there is some conflict there
there is a sense that the scouts and the
front office love kayvon thibodeau which
understandable right i mean he's my
number two player in the draft wow and
some on the coaching staff love aiden
hutchinson and maybe that goes into
coaches love high floor players scouts
and evaluators at the top love guys that
can become superstars uh so i'm very
fascinated to see if trayvon walker goes
number one who's going to win that
battle
i want to hop in because here's the
thing and richard sherman said it right
the word potential and i've always heard
potential get you fired right that's
what i think about all the time
potential does get you fired and so
if they've only if you
if you've only viewed kvon thibodeaux as
potential you're not watching what he's
actually produced and i think that's the
case here if you're a coach and all you
want is the high floor player you're
missing out on a guy in k mod thibodeaux
who did everything that aiden hutchinson
has done
did it better
and was able to be for a longer period
of time and was able to be a true game
wrecker and i think that's the thing i
love about kt coming from the west coast
and his ability to he can play standing
up and we talked about kelsey mentioned
versatility right he we've seen him play
standing up yeah we've seen him play at
that five we've seen him play we've seen
him play essentially a stand-up wide
nine we've seen him play at seven we've
seen him play at five we've seen him
rush to from the end to the interior
from that five we've seen him do a bunch
of those different things yes so the
versatility is there the production is
there and it's all on film so to me it's
not a potential
verse reality situation because the
reality for kvon is there can i be i
just want to be devil's advocate because
i don't want to do this when whoever
takes thibodeau ends up making the pick
this draft reminds me of the 2013 draft
where we didn't have a quarterback taken
till pick 16 which was ej manuel first
six picks in that draft were three
offensive linemen three defensive
lineman which could totally happen
tonight and there was a pass rusher out
of oregon taken by the name of dion
jordan and i heard the same thing 250
fast quick and do everything but he was
too small and he wasn't fast enough why
is this different because you have you
guys have both watched a lot of them
he's number two on your bird it sounds
like he's high on your board yeah i
think he's probably he's a top two
tougher player for me and the thing i
look at with him is
the strength the speed to power and i
know we joked about it pre-show but the
reality of it is his speed the power is
tremendous when you see him lock out
that long arm and walk an offensive
tackle back into the quarterback's lap
that is not he's not fast enough that's
not he's not strong enough that he's
fast enough to be incredibly strong and
i love that about his game and then when
you see him be fleet of foot right i
love that he can bend that edge he's got
that flexibility to do those things so
it all checks out for me this isn't dion
jordan these are different players dion
jordan's the guy that's please don't
touch me that's the way i get to the
quarterback yeah caleb thibodeau's like
touch me if you want to but i'm going to
get you next time i understand why
people fall in love with walker because
when you look at the measurables what's
insane
thibodeaux is a 64250 guy walker's a 6'5
270 guy yeah ran a 451 to a 458 with a
1-5 split and his arms
35 and a half i mean that's like some
evan neil arms you talk about that it's
full extension and yet one guy
constantly got to the quarterback at the
college level for three years and the
other guy never had a breakout season
playing around the best college defense
i've seen in a long time yeah i'll give
him i would give him that as a caveat he
didn't get asked to do all you're 100
right and that's hard to diagnose but
why
exactly that's one of my biggest things
when it comes to
college football coaches only ask you to
do what they know you can do
and that's that's a big part of this
here with me is how come they didn't ask
him to do more how come they didn't put
more on his plate i do think going back
to kelsey's point i do think that
versatility the idea of taking a guy
that is that 270 playing him as a true
defensive end early in this early in the
in the snap count first down second down
and then if you can get him into third
and long because he has the strength
that functional ability to stop the run
being able to kick him down to rush from
the inside while you bring somebody else
it's quicker off the edge that is a
positive from a scheme standpoint the
other thing that kelsey said there about
mike caldwell there is always an
interesting dilemma when you have a
coaching staff that is new but a gm that
is not yeah and the number one thing
that you need
is buy-in from both and if and we saw
this with john lynch and kyle shanahan
early they came in together they were
aligned we both want to be here for six
years don't draft guys that i need to
figure out or then you get into the bill
parcells let me shop for the groceries
um so can we throw up your you want to
do the big board or your mock let's do
the big board can we take a look at
conor's big board and just see how
because this will not be how the draft
goes right but this is how you are
ranking the players for the draft your
number one player is ikea kwano i mean i
just look at the impact run blocking and
there's just not a lot of guys that come
around like this and i think the most
important step for him to go from being
a potential fringe round one player uh
coming out of the 2020 season was
improving in pass pro and he took a
gigantic leap in that step lefko where
you look at it with iquanu his short
area athleticism he'd be an elite zone
blocker he is an elite zone blocker
right now so what he can do in the run
game he could change your entire offense
and he's fine in pass pro
man and you got linder bomb at center
and again positional importance changes
where guys get drafted yeah
who who do you think here could end up
being the value guy that might fall down
board i don't think linda bomb will go
off the board tonight which to me is you
don't think he goes in the first round i
would be surprised if he goes in the top
20 25. can i bring on jason kelsey
you're one of the best centers i've ever
seen that's my comparison for linderbaum
really before we knew kelsey was doing
the show that's who he reminds me of
kelsey what do you think of tyler
lindenbaum
i love him i mean he's one of the most
dominant centers that's come out in a
long time
um you know he unfortunately plays the
position of center it's a
center's a tough position to draft
you're only
there's only one guy that's going to
play that position for the year
hopefully barring injury so
you know when you pick talk about
defensive events talk about defensive
tackles you're talking about receivers
uh even guards or tackles there's a way
to find a place for them on the field to
justify the value of of a first round
pick so with centers you're really only
looking at a few teams that are looking
for a guy to come in and play right away
and start uh you know linderbaum
certainly fits that mold especially with
his own scheme uh obviously everybody
compares them to me i reminds me a lot
of me really uh it reminds me a lot of
ryan khalil yeah i mean
this guy's a you know he's he's a tough
hard-nosed player a former wrestler i
love seeing offensive linemen there are
former wrestlers beat tristan worse in a
wrestling match
bigger
that tells you alone
that he's got great uh that he can
handle size so i mean this guy's got a
lot of really really good traits um but
there there's a number of centers i like
in this draft uh but linda balm is
easily the most productive and uh
consistent player coming out of college
kelsey you're the man it's it's
interesting to me we have all these
first-round pick quarterbacks that went
last year lawrence wilson we're talking
about oh you need to get why not give
him a center that he can play with for
the rest of his career they might have
33. and he's gonna oh that's a good
point
the pick is it okay the pick is in we
were gonna show you a tweet that the
odds were so far in favor of trayvon
walker that they're off the board and
albert beer apparently will be a guy
breaking pics for us tonight the jaguars
are taking georgia edge rusher trey
vaughn
walker it officially happened
trayvon walker we didn't know who was
going first to jacksonville but it is
him his measurables are off the chart he
is a son of a marine and he became a
team leader for the georgia bulldogs in
his junior year
fast 40 big player but i know he wasn't
at the top of your board your initial
reaction to this pick it's it's sadly a
reach right and with trayvon walker i'm
not worried about bust potential right i
don't think he'll be a bad nfl player
he's a super high floor run defender
he's great at the point of attack when
you look at the athleticism and
measurables and when you watch the tape
you want you can trust him at three tech
you can trust him at five tech he can do
a lot of different things for you but
when you draft a guy number one overall
you are expecting him to be a superstar
at a very important skill in the nfl and
that is rushing the quarterback and this
is a player that in his quote-unquote
breakout year this year had six sacks
playing for an elite defense and i know
some people say the opportunity wasn't
always there but the overall pass rush
win rate is just what scares me when you
look at it on tape there's no pass rush
plan it's am i stronger than you can i
push you into the pocket can i bull rush
you and if i can't i don't see a counter
move i don't see a lot of finessibility
i don't see a speed rush once again i
see somebody that's very strong at the
point of attack and this isn't as much
about trayvon walker but more so what
they passed on so i have a lot of
concerns with this selection i think for
me uh it's a c because once again i
don't think he'll be a bus i don't think
he'll be out of the league in four years
i think he'll be a long time starter but
i'd be shocked if he ever develops into
a double-digit sack artist yeah i think
you're hitting the nail on the head and
that's the key right you draft this guy
to be a double-digit sack guy and so
when i look at him play i think that's
going to be what does he become and
that's going to be on the coaching staff
remember this is a guy that's going to
have to develop a second move a counter
move a move a counter to a counter so
that's what we're going to have to see
out of him uh for me when i look at this
and i know we're going to get some more
thoughts on him yeah i'm going to go
ahead and i'm going to knock this one
down i'm going to give it i'm going to
give it a b because i think the
potential is there and i do still like
potential and i like what he can do yeah
so i'm gonna give it a b i'm not gonna
be as harsh as conor but i look at it
and i just he's gonna have to take some
coaching he's gonna have to grow as a
player when he walks into the locker
room of the jacksonville jaguars the
team will be excited he's got a ten and
three quarter hand he's got an 84 and a
quarter wingspan he is an enormous human
being that is fast jason kelsey you have
studied the trenches for us what is your
read on trayvon walker what do you think
of this guy coming out of georgia
yeah i mean you guys just touched on it
i mean he's a guy with unbelievable
physical gifts i mean you look at his 40
his 10 yard split his arm length uh you
know this guy can play all over the
place 270 plus
you're seeing him right now over a guard
i mean he can drop in coverage i mean
the guy is
he's got a lot of versatility and i
guarantee that that's what the coaches
saw
you know he's very unpolished as a
rusher he needs to get a lot better on
that connie talked about not having a
plan that shows up a lot on tape
he's really an athlete out there playing
to some extent a little victim i think
all these georgia guys there's so many
good players on that defense
that uh they they kind of got caught up
in uh the wash it looks like it will be
never really stuck to one spot
to really develop as a player so the
potential is unbelievable um and i think
that that's why they're going with this
kid but to pass on thibodeau and
hutchinson that's that's a lot because
both of those guys you know i think are
going to be
very very good rushers right off the
gate so
um you know we'll see yep back to back
first pick of the draft for the
jacksonville jaguars who went from
trevor lawrence and now trayvon walker
second pick is in and it's already been
reported uh connor hughes who was our
superstar last year no relation to
connor rogers aiden hutchinson the pick
for the detroit lions uh they slipped he
grew up 15 minutes away from the
practice facility played at michigan and
now he will be going to the detroit
lions which is pretty darn special i'm
going to want to go right to ra just to
get his initial reaction but let's let's
roll some beautiful bean footage uh and
see this guy but aiden hutchinson have
been rumored all along to be going the
first pick in the draft aiden hutchinson
goes number two consensus all-american
18 and a half sacks jim harbaugh said
he's one of my absolute favorite guys
that i've ever coached for all the right
reasons
let's go to amman ross st brown other
detroit lions you kind of said before
the draft this would be the right fit
your reaction to aiden hutchinson going
to the lions at number two
man i'm excited i think he's going to
add a a whole new dynamic to our defense
um being able to get to that pass rusher
is going to be so huge for us it's huge
in the nfl it's a passing league now
teams love to throw it if you can
disrupt that quarterback you'll be in
good hands so getting 80 hutchinson for
us is going to be huge i'm excited i'm
pretty sure he's excited too hope he
enjoys the night with his family but
when he gets back out here it's time to
work baby time to bite some kneecaps
thank you aman ross st brown let's get
now to connor rogers where is aidan
hutchinson on your board and the thought
that he falls to the lions here at two
yeah number three overall player i mean
you have to love it right when you look
at him just getting him in this spot uh
this is who they've wanted for a long
time like i said there were evaluators
in that building that did like k-von
thibodeau but the coaching staff this
was absolutely their guy so when you
look at aiden hutchinson this is a
pro-ready player this is a guy that's
going to come in and be really
productive right away what do you think
of ferguson oh we're going full on great
here yes all right i'm going with an a
minus right because i have to be honest
here i did like the upside of kayvon
thibodeaux but i love what aiden
hutchinson brings right away he's he's
refined he's polished he's extremely
athletic he's not on the level of our
typical prototypical uh first overall
edge rusher pick right he's he's not
nick bowser he's not joey bosa but can
he be the light version of that kind of
player with his ability to win on the
outside set tackles up long term what i
loved about aiden hutchinson was by
quarter three quarter four you start to
see them set wide and he knew how to
counter inside and that closed out
football games they were 30th in sacks
last year the lions were they were last
in quarterback knockdowns how much does
aiden hutchinson change that right away
i think he changes it immediately and i
think the cool thing with him is in the
reality
he is not again the prototypical guy we
see at the top but what he is is a
worker and he's an earner and i like
that about him i think he's going to
come in there and he's going to help set
a tone right that coach we know the
coaching staff wants to be wants tone
setters they want hard football guys i'm
on rod st brown that's a hard football
guy and so aiden hudson is going to come
in as a hard football player i'm also
listen i'm going to give this thing an a
and i think the big reason why i'm going
to give it an a and not the not going to
drop it with the minus is because he is
a local guy right and when you get that
local guy you get some energy you get a
little bit of boost now it's going to be
a lot of weight on his shoulders but i
think he's strong enough to carry it
what's in the seats hutchinson said and
this is a quote i'm willing to die for
this i swear i want it more than anyone
i promise you that the other thing
that's important to notice for the
detroit lions second year in a row they
take maybe the best guy in the trenches
that falls to them last year was penney
sewell now it's aidan hutchinson i want
to go back out to jason kelsey had a
chance in the trenches to scout these
guys if you were facing aiden hutchinson
on the other side jason kelsey what
would the thought process be of of what
this team could be getting in the long
term
well first of all i'm thankful i'm
playing center so i don't got to block
this guy that much he's going to stay
out there on those edges but you know
michigan's jumping for joy at this they
get a local guy from the university of
michigan and he's by far the most
polished and complete
rusher in this class i mean he can go
through you around you inside it's all
choreographed it's clearly planned he's
got a i mean he's smart he's physical
he's tough plays you the heck of the
whistle
um
and and the measurables really aren't
that bad i know he gets the
short arms and whatnot but
i mean 4.15 shuttle yeah
6.733 cone i mean when you 1.5710 when
you look at the metrics really where he
plays the game at um i think that this
guy could be something special and um
you know reminds me a little bit
probably not as good of a pure fluid
athlete that joey bosa is uh almost like
a mix between joey bosa and jared allen
where you can tell he's got like this uh
he's got something to him that is just
savvy and uh and then when you tack on
the production 102 pressures 14 sacks
this last year um you know i think
i think this is a home run hit for
detroit uh and hopefully it transitions
to the next level i mean
uh should be a great pick lions fans
have to be excited with that one uh we
want to tell you guys something here
with the br app we got comments right
here we're going to be looking at them
but we also have something new for you
to check out that we're just launching
today it is called br rooms uh it's
gonna be like up you click on your name
and all the team logos are gonna pop up
you click on one of that and there's 32
rooms you want to talk to eagles fans
lions fans you want to celebrate aidan
hutchinson jaguars fans you want to tell
them why we're wrong and why was a home
run pick go in your room debate the pick
analyze the pick all that we got some
comments here i'm a little bit blind and
also felder's so good looking that i
really can't look past him uh but those
are some of the comments but check out
the room these are the comments in the
lions room right now i'm seeing a lot of
yes i'm not seeing a lot of curse words
we did it
match
one pride
so the pick is in there picks in and we
have it connor you want to announce it
for us derek stingley to the texans so
your initial reaction
i'm not surprised this has been building
for a while um we'll actually break down
the pick in the grade
derek stingley going to the texans so a
little bit of a surprise
first quarterback off the board goes to
the the houston texans at pick number
three mr derrick stingley at a lsu who
came to lsu right away and i believe was
the first cornerback
the first true freshman to start for the
tigers in 34 years conor where was he on
your board and are you surprised he goes
this high no because of once again what
he can be right so he's my 17th overall
player which might seem low but that
does take into account that he missed
this year due to injury he had the list
frank injury a very significant injury
for a cornerback 2019 was tremendous
2020 was good didn't look like the same
guy we saw in 2019 where he got drafted
after that year left go top five pick
he's a press man corner he's got deep
speed he's athletic he doesn't have the
best length but he's got the height and
he can turn and run down the field with
vertical targets he has no problem
coming up and tackling so when i look at
stingley what he can be at his peak in
2019 he'd be a top five player in this
draft i just have concerns about staying
healthy long term and staying locked in
long term it's the 2019 2020 scare for
me so this is not a bad pick it is
swinging for the fences for a franchise
that has no identity no blue chip
players no superstars and i have to
respect that but i like sauce gardener
better in this class so it's a b minus
for me there is risk here but it is
absolutely that home run cut you're
right i didn't even think about the fact
that he went ahead of sauce which that's
all we've been hearing your initial
reaction to this i love stingray the
guy's awesome right and i love that we
put some clips on there that showed him
being physical because yes he is a man
corner yes he is a guy that we like to
see in that position but he also is not
afraid to come off and make a tackle so
the big the big thing for me you see him
there coming down to make a tackle
explode force the fumble yeah you want
to see that out of him as well i'm
excited for what he can be obviously
folks that don't realize the lsu houston
pipeline uh in terms of those those
places being kind of combined is huge
yeah so for me looking at the way he's
able to play looking the way he's
tenacious relentless i don't know about
for you connor connor but watching him
always trying to remember what number he
was wearing was a bit of a chore
but ultimately this to me
this is it i'm going to go with an a
minus on this one because
i like sauce just a
smidge yup this is spitch yeah a skosh
if you will yeah so i'm gonna but
honestly i think it's still a really
good pick if you're looking for a corner
stingley junior more past defendants
than start 26-25
let's go to one of the greatest
cornerbacks of all time richard sherman
what did you think watching this guy's
film and how does he fit into this lovey
smith defense where the role will be
very defined what's your
take well i mean i i know lovey will
find a way to use him effectively i i
agree with connor you know i think if
you if he would have went his freshman
year where he was a all-american and he
started for the national champions i
mean he goes top five and there's
nothing to complain about there's you're
excited the guy is freaking on his way
to be an all-pro player but then you see
the last two years you see the year
before
where he was productive but you you're
not seeing the all on ball production
that you're used to seeing or that
you're expecting to see from a freshman
all-american all-american uh and then
you see the injuries so i mean he's he's
kind of slowed down in terms of momentum
i wasn't expecting him to go top three i
i expected sauce to go ahead of him just
because of the year he had but i mean
there's the potential and like i said i
hate to see the potential but his tape
from 2019 looks fantastic his tape from
2020 does not look fantastic it does not
look like a top five pick after that you
don't see him so i mean it's it's a high
risk high reward there there are people
that say he he may be the second best db
to come out of lsu and that's that's
coming from a db coach that's coached a
lot of greats coming from lsu so we'll
see what it looks like in the league
who's number one pat pete
they said tyron really wow tyra matthew
also a part of that 2013 draft richard
sherman thank you sir yeah i i
look i thought there was going to be a
run on offensive tackles i thought there
was going to be a run on pass rushers
wasn't expecting a corner back there but
i had heard rumors but this is your pick
now this is the jets
i'ma let you just go bro it's
fascinating right because everybody's
probably thinking sauce gardner because
he's one of the best players on the
board they need a corner i know they
paid dj reed who's excellent um but i
don't believe that's what robert sala
will look to do i look i think he would
look to build the front four
hutchinson's gone joe douglas offensive
line i've said for months and i've not
moved off this and i know there's a lot
of questions to answer after it because
of mckay beckton and george fan i would
be shocked if they pass icky iquanu in
this spot he's just he's too good he's
the number one player on the board in
the entire draft for me a lot of people
i talked to an offensive line coach last
week from the nfc who was like i would
do anything to get this guy they just
don't come around not every year not
every two years not every three years so
i know that the jets seem like their
offensive line is set but this is an
opportunity to make it better and
unfortunately i don't know how high that
coaching staff is on mackay bechten
right now so this this is what i want to
ask this is what i wanted to get this
one here because that this is this is
your squadron
is this the guy you want them to take
or the like if they pick evan neal
instead of icky what's your reaction
going to be the pick is in guys i would
go with the quantum he's the number one
player in the entire draft and the run
impact run blocking is on a different
level all right okay i'm nervous
and the pick is in
and the pick
sauce garger is the pick
now the jets do have pick number 10.
but i don't know if he's falling there
with the fourth pick in the draft the
second cornerback is taken and it is a
cornerback that shut down wide receivers
all year the man so nice he goes by
sauce 6-3 190 with a 4-4-1
in 1
hundred and three career snaps
he allowed zero touchdowns
last year he didn't allow a catch over
20 yards
connor rogers mr j ets just just jets
your thoughts getting him here at number
four well number one an excellent player
right and we just talked about this
previously when derek stingley went
third overall sauce gardener is the best
corner in this draft right now it's the
athleticism it's the size it's the
spider-like arms it's multiple years of
tape ball skills i think he's good in
press man i think he's got excellent
eyes and instincts and plant and drive
for zone and you see it right there the
ability to tackle which in this league
you see so many teams playing wide zone
run schemes if you're a corner you got
to come down and tackle that's the name
of the game so he's a complete player
he's a really really good player i still
have concerns about this team up front
with their front four the defense they
run with robert salad the pass rush is
simply not good enough yet and you pass
on kavon thibodeau here who was a higher
ranked player for me that's a risk but
they also needed corners so sauce the
best one in the draft he changes that
secondary you have him and dj reid now
yes that's a much better looking unit
this is a b plus for me
you would have maybe liked icky there uh
icky or thibodeaux to me were just more
talented players at spots that the jets
traditionally value the trenches more
with joe douglas and robert salad so
this is a little bit of a surprise if
you don't take him there there's zero
the giants were taking him
so that's that i listen i fully believe
in the idea of one hand watching the
other right and so we always talk about
it as the the defensive line being the
ones that help the secondary out but now
what you have is an opportunity for that
secondary to buy some time for that
defensive front that's going to allow
them to create opportunity that's going
to allow them to get to that second move
to squeeze the pocket to force bad
throws because they're going to be able
to cover for that extra beat i think
it's harder but i think you've got the
right guy for it with sauce gardner
because we've seen him do it time and
again so for me i look at this one and
i it's just it's you can't miss i love
this guy watching him play and watching
the player watching him play in a scheme
that asks him to love dbs i do love dbs
and watching them play in a scheme they
asked him to live on an island right
constantly i can't this is absolutely
you're getting the best corner after
another corner went off the board so i
gotta go a plus man come on i love it
and i'll say this one more note on sauce
i mean he's looked at as the most
versatile corner in the draft right the
jets traditionally right now are a team
zone on first and second downs money
downs third downs fourth downs get us
off the field they leave their corners
on that island and say you're playing
man i love that better survive motivated
by not being the first corner drafted
that's big let's go to a cincinnati grad
jason kelsey i know he was paying
attention to this guy what do you think
about sauce
god damn it i was really hoping how he
was going to trade up and get this guy
he's the best corner in the draft hands
down saw him in person he looks big this
guy looks like a shooting guard playing
corner in the nfl he's got length uh
he's freaking a michigan native so he's
tough
everything was telling me i wanted this
guy
but
he is the highest pick in cincinnati
history going number four overall i love
it so let's go bearcats oh
you see
i think i just knocked the microphone
down
that was amazing that was amazing that's
how that's how much jason kelsey loves
sauce gardener uh richard sherman your
thoughts on sauce gardener
i think it's a fantastic pick i love
sauce i love his tape i love his press
technique i love his confidence he has
everything you want to see in the
position he has production he has
production in big games the question was
does the competition change when he got
to the college football playoffs his
level of play continued to elevate and i
think robert salah in this scheme is
perfect it's it's a hand in glove fit
for him man i it couldn't i couldn't
have picked a better place for him to
land myself outside of going to san
francisco i'm excited and i'm sure
salah's as excited as i am man it's
gonna be awesome amazing uh you hear
those two guys talk about that connor as
a jets fan how does that make you feel i
mean it's awesome and you look at you
know what salah had when he got to a
super bowl right in san francisco yeah
he had richard sherman right so when you
look at it this jets team does not have
an identity player like that where you
look at that perfectly fits the scheme
not only that but just an elite talent
like that a guy that can take away the
football a guy that you're afraid of on
the field honestly you're afraid of and
that's a difference maker and that's
what they wanted and i mean you see him
he's pretty high on this board much
higher than stingley much higher than
trayvon walker so we're sitting here now
and the giants are up and i think that
they have to be a little bit shocked
because they're going wow we could miss
out on all three pass rushers we might
have to try and get a offensive lineman
here and now they're going we have two
of the next three picks and we might get
two guys that we didn't even think were
going to be possible
i think the giants are sitting in a
sweet spot how do they hit a home run in
these two of the next three well now
they have the opportunity if they want
to wait on the tackle for pick seven but
the problem was they were one of those
teams that was all over sauce gardener
they've hired wink martindale they're
going to play a lot of cover zero
they're gonna play a lot of cover one
they're gonna ask a lot of their corners
the two options that fit that scheme are
now off the board so they could take
icky here right which i think they're
shocked at i think they were producing
bracing themselves for evan neal or
worst case charles cross which is not a
bad worst case all right
panthers have to be ecstatic as well
because now they're getting an offensive
lineman yeah they haven't taken since
2013. but so you would you might wait on
the tackle and go with uh thibodeaux no
if i was the giants i would take icky to
block the panthers from that but i'm
saying if they feel like evan neal is
graded the same for them i don't feel
that way but if they feel that way now
they have the opportunity to wait and
take tibet so they're going to go oh
lyman let's say carolina goes oh lyman
then who do the giants take then two uh
two picks from now they're trying to get
out of the pick they've been trying to
get out of the pick because i've been
seeing a wide receiver and now it's
valuable tibido fell somebody might want
to come up for him the pick is not sense
of lyman could first wide receiver right
because when you get to atlanta you have
a chance for a wide receiver run
felder what's your prediction uh i saw
wow
wow
and the offensive lineman still stay on
the board because it is k von thibodeaux
gabe what do you think he loves it here
we go gabe gomez cameraman loves it
our third pass rusher goes and it's a
man with elite bend it is k von
thibodeau the number one player on a
many people's boards goes to the giants
as he falls in the draft 6-4 250 with a
485 440 unanimous all-american lead
oregon and tackles for loss and sacks
all three seasons
this is the number one guy on your board
two number two guy on your board
what do you think of the giants getting
them here awesome pick for the new york
giants i mean best pass rusher in the
draft has played at a high level for
three years for oregon when he big time
recruit which felder knows all about
from cover and recruiting when he got to
oregon as a true freshman there was no
learning curve slow period it was i'm
going to come in and i can dominate
right away it's the outside speed it's
the speed to power you hear felder say
earlier the long arm move i love the
fire he plays with you see him running
cover right there he's an elite athlete
he's a great athlete and for the new
york giants this is just one of the best
players in the draft fell into your lap
you didn't have to move you didn't have
to do anything i know they liked sauce
gardener i know they liked the tackles
which they could still get at seven now
all three of them are still sitting
there what do you think of him and wink
martindale's defense oh wink's gonna let
him go wink's gonna say pin your ears
back get up fields get after the
quarterback give our corners a fighting
chance thibodeaux can do that you got
aziz ogilari in the second round last
year at a nice rookie season now you
pair him with kt got leonard williams on
the inside this front floor is looking
really really nice for wink this is an
a-plus for me i'm this is a great pick
for the new york giants this is called
value just falling into your lap and now
this is like your favorite player i feel
like yeah it's got to be i mean what do
you want me to do what do you want me to
say we just watched that highlight
package of them we talked about the bend
around the edge we saw him do that we
talked about him everybody's talking
about how travon walker can set the edge
what did he do from standing up he set
the edge from hand down he set the edge
look at what this guy is able to do and
i love this okay
patience don't worry i'm gonna make i'm
gonna make it happen and i'm glad you
mentioned look at him dip that hip get
underneath there and go get to the
quarterback you mentioned him as a top
recruit this is something i always look
for left cub
these guys that come out as five stars
the weight of the world's on their
shoulders all eyes are on them from day
one and all he did was rise to the
occasion and continue to deliver for the
organ ducks he led them every single
year he flat out won them a pac-12
championship game and if you're getting
this guy at this spot boom that's an a
plus wow double a plus
yeah kind of hurts me as an eagles fan
unanimous all-american kayvon thibodeaux
going to the giants here at number five
he also created his own cryptocurrency
it's called dream but with a j
but i i joke true holiday i very nice i
joke about it but i heard people say
that's a concern does he love football
and you guys are both rolling your eyes
this is an annoying thing that white
draft guys say when they're like does he
love that he's a white draft guy yeah
not you but
but like what do you say about when you
hear that about him
it's just old scouts that if you're if
you're not waking up and eating football
for breakfast lunch dinners three snacks
in between and don't do anything else
they don't like you and kayvon has
interest outside of football but
football is first second and third so
i i found him in new york city i found
it ridiculous yeah and he's built to be
a star right he's had cameras on him for
a long time this is not going to faze
him at all wink is a player's coach too
this is the right fit for him yeah i
mean look again that's why i brought up
being a five-star this kid has known the
spotlight forever it's been on him
forever yeah there has never been a time
when he didn't have an iso shot you guys
know how it is how it looks when they
shoot a game he's got an iso he's the
guy when you're in the production
meeting there's a cameraman and they're
just like make sure we get a kt iso
full-time that he knows with the
spotlight's on him he knows he has to
deliver and all he's done is deliver i
don't think it's a problem does he love
football absolutely yeah this guy just
knows how to get the job done 34 sacks
last year for the giants they've been
really taking shots at a pass rusher and
really he was the last elite other than
johnson florida state but seemingly of
that top crew now it looks like the
giants are going to get a top pass
rusher and a top offensive lineman and
two picks should be interesting panthers
are coming up now what are you looking
at what's got your attention i'm just
watching kvon thibodeaux and then
there's kids screaming on stage
going nuts uh carolina panthers they
have had eight different starting left
tackles in eight years yes uh and yet
they've only spent two of their 18 picks
on offensive linemen they've been
looking for a left tackle since jordan
gross left
they still don't know their quarterback
so i guess
maybe but what are you thinking here for
the panthers are they excited with how
the board has fallen i think they are
because they have their pick of the
tackles right and now it's a matter of
what kind of tackle do they want dude
and and maybe they do feel some calls
here i feel like they move back and they
do look the quarterback root that's
something we've heard for a while but
when you look at them on paper
you should sit here and take the tackle
whether you want the skyscraper and even
kneel whether you want the short area
explosive leverage monster nikki akwanu
those are the two guys that in my
opinion would be in play here charles
cross would be a bit of a surprise but
still a really good player yeah i mean
listen the panthers they they've got
it's an interesting situation for them
because this is a team that in all
reality
they have to do something this year
those folks are getting frustrated in
charlotte they have to do something
there people yes that's something that
makes people they got to do something
that makes people excited is it going to
be icky maybe because he's an nc state
guy right they'll feel good about that i
think that's a possibility the
quarterback is an interesting dynamic
here i thought and we've talked about
this all all basically for the first
half of the year that
the draft really gets interesting at six
it's apparently decided to get
interesting way before
yes and if the panthers go quarterback
at six that feels like they've made a
massive mistake after the way things
have gone
but
are they able to get out of this pick
and still get something else scott
federer loves to trade the gm for the
panthers loves to trade i think it's
interesting in this perspective too
conor
they spent seemingly all of their 2020
picks on defense then they used their
first pick of 2021 on jc horn and it
feels like they've been neglecting their
offense for a while but i feel like you
have some buzzy stuff right here no i
think no i mean we're waiting on the
pick right now i just think when you
look at it they like their wide
receivers they got terrorist marshall
last year who couldn't make much of an
impact
they they're loaded at skill talent
right now the problem has been they just
don't have a quarterback that can move
the needle we saw sam darnold obviously
struggle last year as soon as christian
mccaffrey got hurt it really went
downhill for him as well kyler struggled
when when uh hopkins went out yeah yeah
loser main guy but you're right left
tackle was cam irving and then maybe
they put in brady christensen who was at
byu but that doesn't make a quarterback
feel safe no no the offensive line's a
problem and you just have you have a
surefire answer in my opinion to upgrade
it right here so it's just as much as
we've heard you have three surefires
yeah you really cannot go wrong is icky
your top i'm gonna have a new guy so can
we talk about why let me hear the evan
neal argument i think evan neal is more
complete i think he's a more complete
package he's also a massive human and i
don't know if you guys saw him at the
combine we've talked about this but no
guy that weighs that much should look
that good six seven three thirty seven
yes and that's the small forward
that's down it's like shaq that's down
from when he when what he plays at yes
because he usually plays closer to that
343.45 number wow but his ability to
still use leverage to still get pushed
to still
generate uh movement from guys that are
small that in theory should be able to
get up underneath his pads he's too big
once he starts to lean on you know where
you're going on your back you're going
to be a bug on the rug so i think the
reality of it is to me i like evan neal
more but listen if you take icky it is
icky it's there we go there it is there
we go and you know what evan neil's
about to probably make the giants very
happy he kind of fits the giants even
more someone they were looking at at
five carolina panthers take a left
tackle for the first time in a long time
and he's staying in the state of north
carolina ikem ekwanu i want to say his
full name why because he chem in
nigerian means my effort will not be in
vain and this pick will not be in vain
you're bored where did he stand on your
board connor rogers he is the best
player in this draft right now he is an
impact run blocker that you just don't
see very often he is a very reliable
pass protector and he's even getting
better in that area when you look at
ikky obviously played left tackle this
year he has plenty of reps at left guard
as well
he's just a destroyer the grip strength
is unbelievable to relocate people to
finish his blocks a lot of two for ones
on tape he'll take out a defensive
lineman and he can climb to the second
level and get his hands on linebacker
safety's corner so icky has special
strength but the lower body movement is
just different he's an elite athlete on
the move and if you're looking to run
wide you're looking to get him downhill
he can play north to south as well
there's really nothing this guy can't do
so for the panthers you walk out of this
draft with sure you have quarterback
questions but you walked out of the
draft with the best offensive player
whoever you bring in he will be
protected yes he will be protected and
you can run the ball all day this is an
a-plus pick for carolina i'm glad they
didn't reach on a quarterback i'm glad
they didn't move out of this spot take
the best player that was on the board
the best player in the draft that's
awesome yeah he's a top five player this
guy's amazing and you get him at number
six that's a win-win all the time he is
a really good player and i'm glad you
mentioned that he's a destroyer this guy
is out there he's conan he's he's
absolutely barbarian yes
no the second one conan the destroyer oh
excuse me
but he is a barbarian too he's an
absolute beast out there moving bodies
around i love my favorite parts are
these right here when you look at him go
get one go get another one and then he's
looking for a third and a fourth right
there i love that tenacity have an
offensive lineman i know he's working on
password look at him pass off the twist
right there good feet patient feet solid
feet i like that out of him so for me
yeah this is an a-plus pick as well i
look at him and he's just bringing it
a-plus
he was a state champion wrestler in high
school and he also had 31 consecutive
starts at nc state 27 at left tackle
four at left guard speaking of
consecutive starts jason kelsey has 122
of them jason you see this guy icky
what did you think of looking at his
tape
yeah i mean everybody you know talks
about how athletic he is and how gifted
he is and that's all true and
you know people don't really talk about
how smart and just
incredibly mature the kid is for his age
i mean he was recruited by ivy league
schools
you see the intelligence on tape uh
everybody seems to love them coaches
seem to love them and
usually when you see guys like that
sometimes it's easy to forget
that uh
he will take a grizzly bear swing at you
on the field he is physical he is tough
he is mean he finishes
everything you see out of this kid on
tape is absolutely fantastic
if there's one negative he plays a
little high but i think it's just
because he's so physically dominant that
he can get away with it
you see the bend at times and
i really like this kid a lot he can play
either tackle or guard
i think he can be a great tackle i think
he'd be potentially all pro hall of fame
guard if they slide him inside wow
that's high praise coming from mr jason
kelsey nfl scout said he kept praising
his teammates when all i wanted him to
do was to talk about him and you want to
talk about smart
he's nigerian
niger they're like the smartest people
i've ever met shout out to my wife and
her family our draft coverage is brought
to you by rocket mortgage you like
rocket mortgage i love rocket mortgage
i'm thinking about calling my first kid
rocket and his middle name mortgage if
you're looking for an edge in the home
buying market you've got to go with
rocket mortgage their verified approval
can help you compete in a crowded market
and give you the edge you need sort of
like how
icky is going to give the panthers an
edge for years to come uh
first tackle off the board
overall is there anything else you want
to wrap up with that
well i think we're going to now see the
run be has begun right the giants at
seven they need a right i mean are they
running in for evan neal like are they
like falling over themselves you don't
have to run in right
yeah but i mean like just because
they're like yeah they got to be really
excited with this outcome
and neil and if neil is their top tackle
and they love charles cross too so even
if neil had been off the block they'd be
going cool we got charles cross who we
think can two year starter at left
tackle can play on the right is there a
chance they take cross when i'm over
here saying have a kneel there's a
chance oh yeah they've done a ton of
work on him i just think they've been
bracing themselves for evan neal to not
be there
and now this situation is cause evan
neal obviously started at right tackle
in 2020
when you have cross who would be moving
over after two years at left tackle so
maybe there's a different comfort level
there are we surprised felder at how
this draft is falling i think stingley
made it interesting who now are you
looking oh this gem is falling and i
would need to pick them up other than
the tackles that we've been i mean
there's a there's a obviously you
mentioned the tackles but wide receivers
garrett wilson jameson williams um we're
almost out of the top ten
we're almost there seven eight nine ten
that's all we got left i saw a number of
mocks that showed a wide receiver run
starting now but that was implying that
the other tackles had gone exactly and i
kind of was expecting the wide receivers
to go seven eight nine the rumors about
candarius tony with the giants the
falcons having maybe the worst wide
receiver room in the nfl nine the
seahawks that was maybe more of a trade
out because the seahawks are sitting
there go you ain't getting wide
receivers for drew lock we just need to
talk about it but i already got to yeah
i mean you got dk and lock it yeah uh so
here are the picks thus far
uh you guys gave the best grades for
thibodeau and hutchinson and
icky for you
um
what are your predictions who's your
predictions for the giants i do think
it'll be evan neil once again i wouldn't
be shocked if it's charles cross the
ultimate wild card here is and they are
playing with fire if they don't go
offensive line
you know how much do they
not value the previous regime's wide
receivers right they didn't they weren't
the ones that paid kenny gallagher they
didn't draft cadarius tony i would
assume we're getting a right tackle here
we are and we are getting evan neal gabe
are you excited gabe is losing his mind
this is what happens when you have a new
offense you have a new gm joe shane in
one draft is seemingly righting the
wrongs of dave gettleman before our eyes
came on thibodeau to start off and now
evan neal who some compare to large
buildings look at those six seven and a
half 337 his arm length is the size of
connor rogers torso speaking of kyra
rogers where did you have evan neal and
what do you think about the giants
getting them here i love it fourth
overall player in the draft when you
look at it i keep saying it skyscraper
over tackle he started a guard in 2019
right tackle in 2020. left tackle in
2021 he's played in a lot of big
football games for this alabama team
love his drive blocking his ability to
re drive guys down the field is he the
most balanced guy on the move in zone
schemes or in pass pro no but when
you're that big that he still can
redirect he can recover you see the feet
there at that size he does everything so
well the length in pass protection shows
up not a lot of guys can beat him wide
it's impossible to cross his face he's
got strength he's got power he's got
excellent work ethic he has there's not
a lot of guys six foot seven to play
offensive line carry their weight like
that it's unbelievable the giants have a
had not have had a massive hole at right
tackle and they just knocked it out of
the park this is an a plus pick getting
a top five player at seven at the most
important position right now on this
football team and this is your number
one player we're gonna keep tackle we're
gonna keep we're gonna keep getting a
pluses because of the way the draft is
shaking out we're gonna keep getting a
pluses this is this is a dream come true
you mentioned gabe losing his mind
because he got the best pass rusher and
the guy i think is the best tackle like
okay and he got conor's second best
tackle oh wow that's so terrible to do
that at five and seven yes that's unreal
so yeah this is an a-plus for me i mean
it just like hot
tonight's tonight's already getting
silly it's unbelievable evan neal by the
way just looking at some stuff he was
the number one offensive tackle in his
recruiting class his entire college
career only allowed five sacks and he
missed one game in the last three
seasons and that was a covet 19 excuse
it was not because of injury and last
year just one penalty jason kelsey pro
bowl all-pro center for the philadelphia
eagles this guy is in the division this
was a hole for the giants it looks like
they filled it what did you see from him
on the tape
uh well i really hate the way this draft
is going for the giants so far uh you
know this kid is very good um
you know neil is probably the most
polished tackle uh definitely the best
pass protector
he's massive
i mean you don't see guys six seven and
a half 340 pounds all day i mean didn't
do any of the running drills but you can
see on tape that he is more than agile
enough uh and something i love when i
watch his tape is the balance i mean the
guy just never looks like he's out of
position nothing ever looks hard and
that's what you see when you see the
best players i mean he's just always in
control look at this i mean you
shouldn't be able to do that to a
division one college football player
um i mean
he's he's a tremendous player and not
only that
he can play other spots i mean at that
frame you don't see guys slide down and
play guard yeah and i don't think the
giants are gonna use them like that but
he can bend so well he could play guard
i mean he's a freshman all-american as a
guard
um you know this kid is a really really
good player uh and unfortunately the
giants just got a giant and uh we're
gonna have to deal with them now yes you
will jason kelsey thank you so much yeah
the giants seem to have fixed their left
tackle a few years ago with andrew
thomas then they go out there and they
get max garcia left guard this off
season john feliciano comes down he
follows brian dabal from buffalo he'll
slide in at center they get mark
lewinsky from indianapolis and now
suddenly you put evan neal at right
tackle and there is an offensive line in
front of daniel jones and now
there are no more excuses bingo
yeah and now
we are going to find out and so they've
invested as a pass rusher on the d line
a right tackle on the o line and i think
jason said it too because i've seen this
with the eagles when you have a guy that
can play multiple positions and and all
the in a you know for an offensive line
to be healthy throughout an nfl season
it's a zero percent chance and this guy
can fill in everywhere the giants have
to be thrilled yeah you've got to be
thrilled he's again he was my favorite
guy coming out he's he's done it already
we talked about this at the top of the
show right with respect to potential
production and all those things he's
played guard he's played right and left
tackle and so what you have is a guy
that probably should be your starting
left tackle wow we'll start him at right
tackle yeah and then we'll see where he
goes from there you know what i remember
andrew thomas played both tackle
positions as well so there's a chance do
you got something i know i'm working
working on it okay uh atlanta falcons
are up and we are entering life after
matt ryan for the atlanta falcons we
were wondering when was it going to
happen the transition starts now matt
ryan traded to indianapolis for a third
round pick currently the starter for the
falcons is marcus mariota we're going
into year two of arthur smith that wide
receiver room is wide open they have no
calvin ridley suspended for the season
because of gambling
tell you what bandul's a tough thing to
put down
it is i get it uh defense though
last in sacks in the nfl they were also
second to last and rushing offense this
is a team that kind of needed everything
so how did you approach them when you
were mocking or predicting picks that's
the hardest part lefko is they do need
everything so you often go best player
available at premium needs right i look
at a team that could knock it after the
quarterback last year they just couldn't
do it the dante fowler signing did not
work out for them they've had a lot of
problems on the defensive line so edge
is in play here you think of jermaine
johnson right away a player like that
but this wide receiver room guys without
calvin ridley
i mean it's xfl level i'm not trying to
be mean i'm just being honest marcus
mariota doesn't stand a chance
and there you go and there is our first
wide receiver taken and it is
the solid and the tall
drake london which means that i think
drake just won a few hundred thousand
dollars betting drake
220 drake london the pac-12 offensive
player of the year described by coaches
as a humble homebody two sport athlete
at usc
his junior year first time he only
played football in his entire life i
talked to coach as a head coach in the
nfl that said this was his favorite wide
receiver he hoped he'd foul he didn't
first wide receiver taken first wide
receiver off the board uh aau basketball
background so when you look at him
played at usc played around 205 pounds
then he had time obviously after the
with the injury and just getting to work
out and getting to work out more in an
nfl level program get up to over 215
pounds
physically this guy can be in a
different dimension he reminds me a lot
of cortland sutton when i watch him play
i just look at a player that those 50 50
balls are more 75 25 and you're gonna
see it right here not a lot of great
throws on tape from this usb talking
about him and kyle pitts yeah he just
goes up and makes plays they're trying
to basketball everybody right box them
out i don't need that much space but i
got enough juice to create space high
point the football he blocks his tail
off coaches are going to love that he
plays hard he plays with an edge he's a
big play monster he's not the fastest
after the catch but he's strong after
the catch with the stiff arm so not my
top wide receiver i felt like garrett
wilson and jamison williams had more
upside than drake london but a top 20
player a significant position of need
i'll go with the b-plus here this is
going to help atlanta it gives them a
little bit of an identity right now
mismatch player kyle pitts mismatch
player drake london mismatch player
quarter l patterson it's a little scary
to see fits what arthur smith had in
tennessee when they had julio and derek
henry it fits that narrative what do you
think of the pick yeah i'll be quicker
because i want to hear what amman rosse
brown has to say yes former teammate
yeah he probably knows pretty well i'm
going to go with it i'm going to go with
an a here because
no he's i thought jamison williams was
better but
i like the plan and that's i'm giving
them bonus points for the plan the plan
of having mismatched guys is the plan of
having guys nobody wants to cover and a
lot of times nobody can cover a monroe
st brown went to usc knows this guy very
well let's get right to him your
thoughts and your guy drake london going
eight to the falcons
yeah you know i think this is a great
pick obviously going to usc i think he's
the best student in the draft i might be
biased but you watch his tape you know
having played with him i remember when
he came in freshman year he just got so
much better each year from his freshman
year all the way to his junior year you
can even watch the tape i mean his
routes look more crisp each year he's
going up getting the ball playing more
confident he does everything like you
said he can block he can make the high
point catch he's hard to tackle that's
something that people don't really
realize is how tough he is to tackle at
times
he'll make one guy miss break another
and he'll get like five six extra yards
with like three dudes on his back so
drake's a beast the falcons got you know
i think the best receiver in this draft
and i can't wait to see what he does the
next level amman i got one uh follow-up
question for you he didn't really run uh
there are some questions about his speed
what are we dealing with speed wise with
drake london
uh you know i think with drake obviously
he kept coming from that ankle injury
didn't be able to run his 40 but
i think he's plenty fast enough you know
people always wonder how fast is he
to me it's all about game speed how fast
are you when you're playing the game and
you watch his tape his game speed is up
there and when you're six four six five
like him you don't have to be the
fastest you throw it up he's gonna make
the play whether you're on him or not
he's going to go up and get it so i know
a lot of people question that speed but
i think his game speed is plenty fast
enough love it i'm on ross st brown
thank you so much yeah so drake london
is the first wide receiver taken what do
you got i i want to point something out
because you mentioned that he was the
pac-12 offensive player of the year i
want people to recognize that he only
played eight games
he had 88 catches in eight games i want
that for halloween but yeah that's 11 a
game i want people to recognize that
this isn't a guy that played all of the
games and was the packed offensive
player of the year he played eight of 12
yes and was able to get the job done so
he is a special talent at this position
that's why and again fitting into that
scheme is important and i'm glad omanra
mentioned the idea that
it's about game speed because something
that doesn't get discussed nearly enough
and it's one of these things that i've
been trying to express to people more
and more nobody runs routes at full
speed you're not supposed to run routes
at full speed that's not the way that
routes work routes have different tempos
different tempos of when you're supposed
to come open different tempos of when
you're supposed to break different
tempos of when you're supposed to sit
down all have different tempos and
london has found an ability to do that
he's found this burst off the ball to
make you think he's going to get over
top of you over top of you and then he
can throttle it down turn around and we
saw it on film go up and high point the
football so i think that's a part of his
game that goes underrated because
everybody wants to know what a 40 time
looks like when the reality of it is
everybody's not out there running a
4-2-40 every single play when they're
playing wide receiver and when calvin
ridley comes back what a great
compliment to those two styles then with
kyle pitts and cordaro patterson it
seems like they have an identity finally
being formed in atlanta and it's going
to be necessary as we move on from the
era of matt ryan pick number nine this
is the seattle seahawks they got this
pick in the russell wilson trade that
they made with the denver broncos there
have been a lot of mocks where this pick
gets traded connor what are your
thoughts at this spot number nine
fascinating spot right a team truly
without a quarterback right a real
answer right now they have plenty of
needs they do pick at 40 and 41 they've
been open to taking calls of getting out
of this pick but it sounded like
exploring see how much you can squeeze
out of it jermaine johnson excellent
scheme fit his ability to get off the
football they love that there in seattle
that's going to make a lot of sense now
also a team that has holes on the
offensive line huge hole at right tackle
or at left they didn't bring back dwayne
brown right stone forsythe is there and
he has never played a regular season
snap yeah he was a project pick last
year on day three so when you look at it
charles cross is in play here
and you know you have to wonder is that
a plug and play pick for them take
charles cross play him on the left side
or do they like the tier two and three
of this offensive line class with that
40-40 maybe i'm a sucker but i think of
the legion of boom with this team does
kyle hamilton fit here at all
no they're paying two safeties right now
they're paying jamal adams they're
paying digs i look at you know they
would have loved i think stingley or
sauce obviously not there mcduffie a
smaller corner i would be surprised at
that selection i just man when you look
at seattle right now they're also one of
the most unpredictable drafters in the
entire nfl so as i sit here and say this
rashad
rashad penny jordan brooks i mean on and
on and on they are very difficult to
figure out because they'll take a second
round player in the first round they'll
move all around the board and then
they'll pick a dk metcalf for the second
and then they hit a home run on tk so
they're all over the place i'm i'm
fascinated by this selection if they go
you know kind of off the rails here do
they just take jordan davis and we're
like what the hell i mean this wooden
shop you know what for a team that's
been unable to stop the run for a few
years but they were 31st against the
past last year but more importantly when
i think of russell wilson these last few
years i think of him running for his
life
25th and sachs allowed last year what do
we think here uh felder is this a place
where you go with a charles cross or do
you go with a pass rusher i think cross
makes a lot of sense because again
you have to find a way to protect
especially when you don't have a
quarterback that you like yeah we got it
okay cross cross there we go
this is a this is a great pick
i was gonna say when you don't have a
quarterback that you like you probably
need to give him more time and so
they're gonna give him some more time
yeah it's drew locke with geno smith
behind him and jacob
we are getting an offensive lineman to
help the seattle seahawks finally
protect their quarterback mississippi
state charles cross 6'5 307 22 starts in
college all of them at left tackle now
the interesting thing is nearly 80
percent of his plays were passing plays
and that's what we're going to get into
now but your initial feel of charles
cross here at 9. i love it and do not
worry about the percentages from the
offense because he wasn't recruited to
play in that offense this man can beat
you up in the run game he's got big bare
grip strength hands he's got long arms
he's got good feet
i mean i love the player i thought there
was a big three of offensive tackles in
this class everybody talked about icky
everybody talked about evan neal took a
long time for people to jump across the
charles cross bandwagon right here ninth
overall player ninth overall pick a
massive need for this seattle team we
don't know what the future holds at
quarterback guess what there wasn't a
guy in this spot that was the surefire
answer so instead you do take the
foundational piece that can build for
whoever that is at quarterback and they
want to run the football like you said
lefko if there are some questions about
because the sample size is a run blocker
the sample that is on tape on the all 22
is excellent north to south wide zone
getting out wide just okay north south
he'll beat you up i like charles cross a
lot this is an a minus pick for a team
that really needed help on the offensive
line tier one offensive tackles gone
this was it yeah we're closing out we're
about to close out the top ten if you
will this is a nine and you get him at
nine a guy that some people thought
could have been in the top seven so this
is a big pick for them we've got we got
to get to both guys so i'm going to go
ahead and lock in the a i don't see how
this is a miss for them because they
help a position of need and they help it
with someone that a lot of folks didn't
expect to be on the board now all right
jason kelsey your reaction to charles
cross going to the seahawks what do you
think of this prospect
yeah i mean he's a little bit undersized
for a tackle light but um you see some
really good production out of them
throughout college
i realized watching a mississippi state
man i love mike leech mike leach's press
conferences but i would hate to be an
offensive lineman in his scheme it is a
lot of pass blocking
and uh and he certainly does a great job
of that he's long his arms they get on
him he's got great hands he finishes
you know i don't see him as this
unbelievable explosive athlete
but but he can definitely move people he
can definitely get on guys and uh he's
got some power to his game despite being
undersized so
this could be a really good pick here he
likely will slide to that left tackle
spot again stone forsythe had never
played a snap in the nfl and he was
going to be the starter let's go to a
former member of the seahawks for a very
long time richard sherman they didn't
draft a lot of offensive lineman when i
feel like you played there your thoughts
on this pick
i i think it's a solid pick you know i
think them starting to try to try to
build the team in that way you know
obviously they've been unpredictable in
the past you guys mentioned the shop
penny pick um the brooks pick uh usually
it's unpredictable for them to take a
tackle that's that was expected to go
much higher than he did um
feeling a position of need
pretty much stealing dwayne brown not
coming back i thought there might be a
trade you know maybe the the metcon
uh the bechten trade with jets you know
he's been made available i thought they
would get involved in that but um it's a
great pick for them all right charles
cross officially a seattle seahawk
sherm kelsey thank you guys very much
the draft now
we're open up to the wild part where we
have a lot of players that are really
great that are still out there a lot of
the great wide receivers are left number
one safety in this draft is left some of
the other corners trent mcduffie are
there but really it's the wide receivers
and the jets are back on the clock
connor from where they picked it for how
has the board fallen for this team
yeah so right now you're looking at i
kind of criticize them with the sauce
pick i like the pick because i love the
player but i said i still have pass rush
concerns jermaine johnson's still there
that would answer those immediately if
they left this draft with sauce and
jermaine johnson how you feeling i mean
one of the worst defenses in the nfl
last year completely flips around under
robert salad now you have talent cause
you got jordan whitehead back to back
right you signed dj reid you draft sauce
gardener
you're finally starting to build
something on the defense that fits the
scheme so that's in play wide receiver
we know how hungry they've been i'm
fascinated if they don't go wide
receiver here do they know something do
they think they can get debo samuel with
other picks is there something there
because they've been
so hungry
so thirsty they do have the third pick
in the second round they do have the
sixth pick in the second round that one
coming from sam darnold this pick coming
from the jamal adams trade let's get
inside the mind of connor rogers who are
you texting right now
what sources are you working i mean i
can't say uh who but i'm trying to
figure out what the jets are doing right
here i don't want rumors wash over you
i've heard some rumors that they've
answered the phones on teams looking to
come up not sure if they want to take
that kind of capital
obviously there are players here that
they really really like they really like
jermaine johnson a lot they really like
this wide receiver class as well they
love drake london though and he's gone
before we know the pick are you going to
be happier with johnson who i know you
absolutely love or if they go out and
get garrett wilson don't show it yet
don't show it yet i would go jermaine
johnson because now i know that doesn't
help zack wilson and that's the argument
i'm a believer they can they can still
find a trade for somebody like debo
jermaine johnson i'm higher on him than
almost everybody that does this for a
living and i don't care i have him as
the sixth overall player he's a stud and
again the jets have two early picks in
the second round where some of this very
deep wide receiver class could get there
this is really it help your quarterback
or hurt the other quarterbacks
you can't go wrong with either of those
if they go off that script all right
here it is
garrett wilson help the quarterback okay
wide receiver number one for me in this
draft uh a blend of a
calvin ridley who we talked about
earlier before the catch kind of reminds
me of cd lamb with the ball in his hands
and you see the ability to get open
excellent feet short area quickness he's
got long speed uh he's he plays bigger
than his size you see the sub 4 4 speed
with the 40 yard dash what garrett
wilson why i valued him as the best
receiver in this draft i love the floor
guys that excel at all three phases
before the catch at the catch point
concentration focus playing big securing
the ball and with the ball in their
hands they succeed at the next level
there's no kenny get open there's no
kenny catch the ball there's no kenny
make life easier on his quarterback by
making plays garrett wilson does all
three things so this pick helps zach
wilson right away they obviously have
not been able to swing a trade they
failed and missed on tyreek kill now
they get a player that is not only pro
ready but also fits mike leflore's
offense i'll go with an a minus here is
there another wide receiver you may have
wanted more than garrett wilson no he's
the top one he's your top you go with
the top one this was a division one
basketball recruit out of high school
ohio state coaches when asked were so
taken away at his professionalism from
the time that he got there you've been
looking at this guy for a long time that
checks out he fits into that cave on
thibodeau mode right a guy that's always
had the spotlight on him and stands up
to the spotlight he is incredibly
professional talked to a couple buddies
our old pal hunter mandel yeah and he
referenced that wilson is such a pro
he's been a pro through the entire
process was a pro in high school when he
was coming out he does all those little
things right and i think that's the big
key here this is a guy that does a
little thing right on the field and off
the field and i love that about him it's
clearly a student of the game
understands again we saw it right there
tempoing out a route not going full
speed until he knows that he's open for
his quarterback and then getting wide
open so for me i'm going to give it an a
i think the really the reality of it is
as we what are we this is pig number two
for a guy that we all thought could have
gone anywhere from five to two to seven
five to eight yes he you get him at ten
this is a win look i know we've gotta
get to i know we gotta get to somebody
else but you're happy how can you not be
and feller i'm so glad you brought that
up because that was something you heard
throughout this entire process coaches
and scouts that got to sit down with
garrett wilson blown away by how much he
can absorb right away we're not talking
about college offense or three routes
we're talking about anything you throw
at me i'm good to go i want the football
i got to go down obviously and see when
they came into town against ruckers got
to watch him in person play speed
phenomenal strength after the catch
phenomenal garrett wilson he he was to
me the best wide receiver in this draft
for a team now you're lining up elijah
moore garrett wilson corey davis you
signed two tight ends it's finally
looking competent on offense all right
elijah moore garrett wilson let's bring
in a monroe st brown you watched some
film of this guy garrett wilson what'd
you come away thinking amonrah
yeah i think this is a great pick i
think this is one of my favorite
receivers in this draft you know
watching his tape i feel like he can do
it all there's not one part of his game
that's really lacking um you know he can
one of the one of the parts in his game
that i really love was his high point
ability i mean you watch his tape he's
burning past guys for most of the part
but
the one play that really stands out to
me is that that play his freshman year
against clemson where he
he jumped like 40 inches in the air and
caught the ball i mean he can his high
point catchability i think is great he's
fast he runs great routes he can stop on
a dime and those are all things you're
looking for in a receiver so this is one
of my favorite receivers in this draft
and i think this is a great pick for the
jets
all right garrett wilson you mentioned
that high point 62 percent success rate
in contested situations for a guy that's
six feet tall
he's explosive and that's what's excited
congratulations on a pretty good draft
so i didn't make the pick but jet's
looking better but you know what you
help out zach and you get sauce they're
gonna have some battles in training camp
pick number 11 the washington commanders
are trading back and the saints move up
this was a thing that we had talked
about the saints had traded with the
eagles in the beginning of this process
to get themselves a second first round
pick and now they're moving up we're not
sure which pick they did to get up there
but the saints moving up what do you
think it's for there's been a lot of
talk recently about them with
quarterback and they have their pick of
the litter right here but man do they
need a tackle they lost her on arm said
now i would not agree with this pick but
i think the league is a lot higher on
trevor penning than media and fans that
would shock me here i want to break that
because there's been a recent run on
tackles they kind of have to your thing
last one the run on receivers has
started i know the jets were not
surprised you're absolutely right the
jets like drake london he went at eight
so then the jets took garrett wilson who
they also really liked but now two wide
receivers are gone chris salabe is going
to go soon we're going to see jameson
williams go soon i know your eagles like
him yes this is berks trailing berks is
going to go in the first round so the
saints are trading their 16th pick and a
third and fourth to washington for the
11th pick saints also have the 19th pick
so they're going to keep 19 they're
going to move up to 11. and this is
mickey loomis trying to get it done
because the big story for the saints we
are now in the post sean payton era i
don't think people realize the kind of
control sean payton had over this
franchise it is a completely different
vibe it is just michael thomas there on
the outside he didn't play last year
they have mark s callaway and traequan
smith if they are definitely coming up
for a wide receiver alvin kamara had his
off-field incident we're not sure what
happens with that they did have some
safety questions which is my only other
thing here marcus may replaces marcus
williams but malcolm jenkins retires
maybe a kyle hamilton thing
man that's a luxury for them right now
though i and i love kyle hamilton and i
know you do too he's trying to put up
other options it's just hard for me for
you to go into the season with jameis
winston and say
we don't really have a left tackle
that's that's tough for me to say now
i'm not saying the answer is here but
i'm how they're thinking
the idea that they're they give they
give up this draft capital to draft
pinning that's not a good move that's
the case exactly so what would be a good
move for them to trade up to do
certainly doesn't feel like it'd be a
good move for them to trade up to get
willis and i don't think they need a
defensive pass rusher to be honest right
a lot of draft capital marcus davenport
like they gave up future first-round
picks to get him what's it what's the
corner what's it what's a good move
what's a good move is it trading up to
get can we see conor's big board i just
want to kind of show you a few of the
names that are possible right now draft
and stash jameson williams is the move
right here that's it for me okay they
obviously don't need linderbaum they've
been drafting centers and guards right
they don't need jermaine johnson
possibly kyle hamilton i like jamison
makes sense jordan davis
not really devin lloyd no so you're
thinking right here it's either a wide
receiver or a reach on attack the value
is that wide receiver because they're
going to go and it i'm kind of surprised
washington was willing to deal with them
because washington needs a wide receiver
they do but they love to trig london and
i think they liked garrett wilson so
they got sniped and if you're sitting
there and you're going hey maybe when we
drop back oh lava will still be there
maybe someone else that can go along
with saints like a larvae a lot too so
this is it seems early for a lava but
they do like him a lot who do we think
the saints are trying to jump up next
was vikings texans ravens eagles you
think they were trying to get ahead
we've been hearing rumors about the
eagles they trying
it's not jumping it's competing to get
up that's what it is it's the fear that
somebody else is going to beat you to
the punch and they went out and got it
done for a third and fourth round pick
which five spots that's not cheap one of
them is a top 100 pick yeah and third
fourth in a draft where all i'm hearing
is you want a lot of thirty fourth
rounds yeah the saints do this every
year though this is the least surprising
thing of the entire night right here
they move up every single year they're
not afraid to play their board um and
and i i do have a real fear here
that it is for a tackle that is a reach
because of the desperation but we'll see
if your fear is realized chris olaver
there you go is the pick
for the
saints they loved him throughout this
process and they were very afraid that
he wouldn't make it to them i thought he
would have they've been looking for
another wide receiver to put on the
opposite side of michael thomas and why
not get another guy from ohio state the
crisp or out running of chris olave we
are moving on from the sean payton era
and we are trying to fill out weapons on
the outside what is the value for
crystal lovely is this where you kind of
saw him going yeah because the run on
wide receivers has started right so he's
my 22nd overall player but you can't
play that when you just saw drake london
and garrett wilson his teammate come off
the board it's it's going hot right now
it's going fast so when you look at it
perfect fit for the saints offense a guy
that's super smooth knows how to get
open creates separation can track the
football now with the lava the lack of
upside to me is that he just doesn't
make things happen with the ball in his
hands he doesn't force tackles he
doesn't run through anybody uh there is
going to be a little bit of an
adjustment here physically because he's
not the biggest guy he's going to see a
lot more press coverage at the at the
next level that he's going to learn how
to get off but he's got the feet and
he's got the releases at the line of
scrimmage to do that so for the saints
here you went up you got your guy you
didn't want to walk out of this draft
without a top flight wide receiver a
lava is one of five that i have a first
round grade on so the value it checks
out the scheme fit is perfect i just
think what you see is what you get with
him which is a good player never an
exceptional player which is why you
draft receivers in the top 15. so for me
a b-plus here rock-solid pick
super super high floor for the saints
the all-time leader in touchdown catches
for ohio state 35 they referred to him
as the big brother in the ohio state
wide receiver room i think a lot of
people felt her were shocked at his 40
time that it was so fast i know you've
been watching this guy for a long time
what do you think of this pick he's got
really good straight line speed but i
label he's kind of a rabbit this is a
guy to me
rabbits don't run in straight lines
usually so while he has that straight
line speed the best part of his game for
me is that little jitterbug element that
ability to bend the ability to move
around to get open and while he does not
he's not a tackle breaker like drake
london right he's not as physical or
much of a high point guy as garrett
wilson but he does have the ability to
understand when he's going to get open
he knows when to leave himself faces
just on that play to fade to the
sidelines i i think that you said you
had five wide receivers graded out as
first round guys i think he's the last
of the five so for me i'm gonna give it
a b minus because yes they did get a
complimentary piece yes they did get
something that could help them but you
could have got two other guys in jameson
williams or or trailing burks that would
have been able to
really be a little i think have a higher
mention exactly physically imposing yes
yeah i'm with you felder let's go to
detroit lions wide receiver at monroe st
brown you're watching a lava on tape and
you came away thinking what
i mean most about the lava is just how
smooth he is um
i watched the combine i saw him on that
4-3 and i didn't know he was that fast
just because how smoothly runs his
routes and everything i think that's as
a receiver that's something people look
for that's something you want as a
receiver so when you're wearing your
routes
dbs can't really tell what you're doing
because you're so smooth coming in and
out of your brakes so that seemed that
really stood out to me watching his game
obviously he's going to be a deep threat
playing along michael thomas i think
it's going to be a good fit for him um
but yeah i really like this receiver i
like the pick and just how smooth he has
really stood out to me amman raw i want
to keep you on right now because your
detroit lions have traded up now into
this spot i got the pick texted to me
and you have the pick text
so then let's bring up amman ross st
brown and connor on camera connor do you
want to tell iman ross st brown who his
detroit lions have taken as we show that
they gave up 32 34 and 66 for this pick
so monroe i just got a text uh from your
building that it is i think you'll like
this i think you're going to have a lot
of fun with this i think you're going to
have a lot of success with this you will
be playing alongside jameson williams in
that offense one day and i think it's
going to be electric watching you guys
we'll get a smile
that's going to be dope
everybody what's your that's a huge fig
i think for us hold on let's go back to
oman ross st brown i'm on yeah what's
your what's your feeling other than this
is going to be dope because it is going
to be dope
uh yeah i mean playing against i watched
a lot of bama games um huge deep threat
jamison williams i think it's going to
be great fit for us someone that can
take the top off the defense um
he didn't run his 40 i don't think he
had to though he we all you watch the
tape he's fast he gets up on his hands
no one's touching him so i'm excited for
this pick you know good to play
alongside him um and a bunch of other
dudes we got so i think it's going to be
dope for our team you got a message for
him that we can pass along
um
get ready get ready to rock out cause
you're about to have a lot of fun baby
hey
i love it all right now let's take a
look at the footage get some grades here
detroit lions said we do not want to
wait around and have to maybe hope a
wide receiver falls to us at 32. there
were teams in the teens that were
looking at jamison williams and the
lions just jumped up their first pick
they're able to find aidan hutchinson
now they get jameson williams arguably
the top two players at their position
what do you think of the lions move and
the player oh i mean love both number
one this is great a great job by brad
holmes to understand how the board was
going to break i've been talking about
this with felder for a long time
when the wide receiver run starts it is
going to come in hot and fast and
everybody thought atlanta is where it
could begin everybody knew the new york
jets were going to be in on it the lions
were ready to pounce and made him move
for my number two wide receiver in the
strap here's the reality you got guys
that are sub 4-3 players that have route
polish are rare they are rare there are
guys every year that go to indy and run
sub 4-3 and the fantasy community and
all kinds of people become obsessed with
them but when you have polish that's
when coaches and teams become obsessed
you jameson williams is my number two
wide receiver in this draft 11th overall
player this is an a minus for me this is
this lion's offense right now you're
starting to see some real playmakers
some real weapons and what jameson can
do as you see the a minus right there is
take defenders out of the box and open
up a ground and pound our guy at monroe
brown's suddenly gonna have a lot of
room underneath to dice up people's
ankles what's your take i love this kid
he's my he's my number one wide receiver
in the draft one of my favorite players
to watch i'm glad you mentioned the
polish because his ability to work tempo
into that route running is absolutely
beautiful you see him here recognizing
hey i got a back pedal i don't have to
run this at full speed i'm going to be
wide open this one right here i got it i
can get open do you see how wide not
just how wide open is but the way that
he breaks up over the top to create that
space he knows when he has to turn on
that sub 4-3 speed to run away from
people this is a great example step
straight and now look at him boom now
i'm going and you're not going to get me
it's okay yes you touched me but you
didn't tackle me uh losing him in the
national championship game was the thing
that hurt alabama the most yes and for
me i think that he is someone that is
just he's incredibly explosive once he
comes back from this injury healthy he
is going to be an absolute nightmare to
cover because if you try to play him in
man he's going to get you leaning and
then he's going to find a way to run
away from you if you're going to play
him in zone he knows where to stop so
for me this is an a plus my number one
wide receiver in the draft my guy that i
thought is going to be an absolute
difference maker at the next level
someone that comes in with polish he's
not going to take time the only time
he's going to need is to be healthy he's
not going to take him time to learn how
to run routes at the next level right he
already can do that we mentioned it with
garrett wilson he can all this is
another one of those players that can
already do that and the detroit lions
trading the pick that they had gotten in
the return for matt stafford to get this
done and we'll see if jamison williams
could be the wide receiver for the
future just want to let you guys know uh
we are way ahead of television they in
fact haven't even announced the lions
pick and because they're doing that
we're gonna take this time for a little
message from rocket mortgage
this crazy suit can give me an edge oh
yeah huge edge
invisibility gives aaron donald an edge
on his game who hit me just like a
verified approval gives you an edge on
your offer i did when you need a
competitive edge in the housing game
rocket cam who's the trace
and look what we come back to the old
dirty birds the eagles are trading up to
13 with the houston texans who are they
going to get connor's first reaction
treylin burks we have a run on wide
receivers it's three in a row for the
last five the eagles are trading 15
124 126 and 166 and i'm gonna be honest
who cares about those picks hang on or
see those picks those picks don't even
exist uh so the eagles move up two spots
to jump the ravens
is there a chance it's for jordan davis
i also know the ravens really like
jermaine johnson so is it true now i
message you guys when you're doing a
live on the br app and i said i feel
like the eagles are going to take
jermaine johnson they've drafted florida
state guys in the past broderick bunkley
comes to mind uh but also i look at this
eagles team and i i don't mean to talk
about people as they get up in age
brandon graham is turning 34 this year
this is a team that is all about
pressures and last year was second to
last in the nfl in sacks brandon graham
has had an incredible career derek
barnett has had an okay career they've
invested a lot in the interior defensive
line javon hargrave milton williams is
coming along and the fact that i told
you guys this
if it is jermaine i'm gonna feel like a
this is a guy that i heard could go as
high as the top five sleeper trent
mcduffie sleeper i mean i know trimming
down he's not a sleeper on anyone's
board but to go here
the fact that the traders traded up and
they still kept their other top 20 pick
is exciting as well so i want your
predictions right now
wow
you know what let me just go with your
main because of the move if you're going
ahead of baltimore but i look at them
left going i do think they they've
invested in edge pass rush recently
you're right hassan reddick assan
reddick that's what and they paid josh
sweat so that's where i'm thrown off
here and you know i talked to germain at
the combine and he he loved he told me
he loves to rush off the tackle's
shoulder so you're not kicking him in
he's a wide rusher
so i look at this for the eagles right
here you know i'll i'll go with trent
mcduffie i just think the league is a
lot higher on him
uh than everyone else has been right i
had him over stingley which i know
people will think is insane but i just
like the floor with trent one of the
smartest players in the draft the best
zone corner in the draft one of the best
tacklers in the crowd who's going to
make me happy belter who are you
thinking i'm going to i'm going to give
lufka the win here okay i'm going to
think about it no i'm going to give him
the win here okay i think it's either
going to be germaine
or i think the name that you guys are
both forgetting is kyle hamilton
i'm not forgetting and i think that you
jumped the ravens maybe i got you got
the pick
and it's fun i like it is it none of the
guys it's none of the guys but it is
somebody that was in play for baltimore
that's the trade up it's jordan davis
wow
yes yes
yes my favorite player in this draft
jordan davis the monster hey let's not
take the biggest fastest strongest guy
that is like all over the place jordan
davis jason kelsey talk to me how we
feeling right now how are we feeling
big
ah let's go couldn't be happier hell
yeah
baby hell yeah
[Applause]
why not just pick the biggest monster
the dancing bear
four seven three hundred and forty
pounds monster of a human being that's a
hard miss that's it's a hard miss
physics do not change
force equals mass times acceleration
whoa
coming right through you
isaac newton loves this pick let's get
into this video i love it
eagles trade up over the ravens because
if jordan davis would have gone the
ravens we would have sat here and go
what a ravens pick what a perfect pick
for the ravens but now he's an eagle
okay we gave the ravens lamar jackson
picked 32 years ago and we're stealing
it back jordan davis i like the pick
what do you think i said that stupid
ravens quote so many times these last
couple months that i'm happy we're here
listen how many human beings do they
make that are this big and this fast it
is unlike anything we have seen before
with jordan davis he can control two
gaps he can control the guy in front of
him he's incredible threat as a run
defender his ability to just eat up
blocks but also push the pocket and just
be a difference maker as a true zero a
true nose but he could play shade nose i
know everybody gets so caught up about
the snap percentage at the college level
georgia had 85 million excellent
defensive linemen that they can afford
to give him rest is there a little bit
more to be desired as a pure pass rusher
yes but i think you can tap into it at
that size at the next level and you know
what he is he will come in and be one of
the best run defenders one of the best
true nose tackles in the entire league
and i like the aggressive nature to jump
baltimore yeah and go get him so you get
bonus points for that a plus for the b
and now you get to be the hater and and
i want you to really let it out i want
you to let it flow don't be worried
about me don't be worried about jason
kelsey just let it flow i'm not going to
be the hater i'm very curious to watch
him in this scheme i'm very curious to
watch do you play him with was it
fletcher cox yep do you play him with
fletcher [ __ ] and hard grave how do you
how does that work though which one of
those guys is coming out
how does that work for them that's the
part i'm curious to see because this he
is a true nose and georgia i want to
give a quick note fletcher cox and
hargrave free agents after this year so
it could be investing in the future as
well i love that because this is a guy
that played in a true three four at
georgia that's the reason why guys like
connor guys like myself said he's a
perfect fit for the raises because he
would have been that true nose right but
the biggest thing for me i want i want
to make sure i get this right because i
do want to say this because we've talked
about this all fair i want to say it on
air the biggest thing for jordan davis
for me was the growth from the sec
championship game to the national
championship game in the sec
championship game we're talking about a
guy on a bama touchdown pass that is
standing straight up looking at the
sideline like coach you got to get me
out of here they're giving me my lunch
and he went to the treadmill my guy
robbie cowan at uproxx wrote an article
that came out today and he mentioned the
idea that hey
he got on the treadmill he put in miles
for real miles so that would never
happen to him again he takes his own
criticism he took the media's criticism
of him and he turned himself into a guy
that's got pick what is this right now
in the top 13 of the nfl draft all
because of what he was able to do
against alabama so no i don't think i
was wrong over the course of the season
but i do think that his ability to make
that transition that does make this an a
let's go plus
give me one oh nick saban said about him
quote he's about as good of a player as
i've seen in a long time as an inside
player on any team and the irony this is
your chuck bednarik award winner
chuck begnaric you know who he played
for the philadelphia eagles concrete
charlie uh i know we were yelling
earlier jason kelsey do you want to put
a bow on it uh what is it going to be
like seeing this mammoth of a man
walking into camp
yeah um first of all love the grade
michael uh i think that uh you know i'm
i'm sure
i'm certainly not looking forward to
blocking him in training camp but i am
looking forward to being on this team
um you know
i actually think he's a really good
scheme fit for us you know gannon likes
to run a lot of five down fronts
uh we like to you know put three d
tackles in the game quite a bit
and i think jordan has the athleticism
and the fluidity to be able to play nose
three or even a four eye
on run down step four eye inside shade
of that tackle uh because of how
athletic he is if he can play that
position that feels a major uh major
spot for us and then uh with milton
williams on the other uh being able to
come in i mean we that defensive line is
so stacked now uh there really isn't a
weakness so i'm excited to see this kid
i'm excited to see him grow
with uh fletcher cox shivan hargrave um
and i'm excited to uh hopefully call
some help from my guard to try and block
him because uh he's got me out weighed
by quite a bit man i love it and you
know what
the fact that they take him who we're so
excited about and the sixers just
eliminated the raptors what a moment
what a moment like what what a last
minute that i just experienced that was
great
uh here are the last ten picks we had
sauce gardener go at four only really
surprising because he was a second
corner taken we wrapped up the edges at
five then we we finished off the the top
tier offensive lineman drake london went
we finished off charles cross it went
wide receiver wide receiver wide
receiver and then defensive lyman right
there and
now we're at this interesting part of
the draft the ravens are sitting there
d how do you think the ravens are
feeling right now the eagles have now
done this multiple drafts in a row
they're okay they jumped in front of the
giants last year and they stole devonta
smith and that left the giants with a
bad taste who do you think the ravens
are pivoting to now if you thought it
was jordan davis jermaine johnson
they need help on the defensive line
they're they have some questions at
tackle because they went out and signed
morgan moses on a three-year
cost-effective deal but ronnie stanley
has had some really tough injury luck
the last couple of years so they've been
beat up on the offensive line they got
their corners back nice and hammered
they tried to sign zadaria smith he
backed out and then went to the vikings
and oda odafa
bauer they're coming off off-season
surgeries i'd be surprised if it's not
jermaine they've been they've been on
him and jordan davis for a long time yes
wow let's go told you
jump up from the ravens to take kyle
hamilton but now to say you're so
excited that's why i said can we pull up
their team knees
let me say this hold on let me just set
it up here we go there are certain
positions that feel romantic and one of
them is an elite safety for the
baltimore ravens it just feels it's a
position that should be perfect and this
guy might be it kyle hamilton 6'4 220
running a 4-5-9 out of notre dame a
two-time first-team all-american goes 14
to the ravens when the ravens take you
it feels like it's a great pick already
what do you think it's a good sign
especially when you play defense now let
me start this for the ravens with a
little excitement i think they have
potentially the best safety duo in all
of the nfl by the end of this year with
kyle hamilton and obviously they signed
marcus williams to a big these guys
complement each other perfectly you have
marcus that can do so many different
things in coverage you have kyle
hamilton who can also do a lot in
coverage but can come downhill run
sideline to sideline blitz he's the size
of a linebacker he can move like a
safety i think for the ravens here this
is all about value you got a top 10
player he's my eighth overall player in
this draft he hits with a ton of force
but once again he can make plays on the
ball because he's got exceptional length
six foot four long arms ball skills
range this is pretty cool this will be
really cool to watch the back end of
that defense they're aggressive with
their corners but you let those safeties
fly around you're telling me chuck clark
is your third safety right now
they're gonna play a lot of three
safeties they might even have hamilton
come down in the slot sure this is gonna
be an ex it always is an exciting
defense to watch this just got so much
more exciting with kyle hamilton this is
an a for me because man they had some
other needs but you took a great
football player
you audibly yelled and fist pumped i
just want to know why i love him the
play that we showed the first play that
we showed on that clip was a guy going
from far hash to near sideline to
intercept the ball that was a busted
coverage that he should have never even
been able to make this is another chance
where you're gonna see a guy just be
just be physical let's go i'm going to
go make a play and i'm going to go ahead
and take the ball away you're not going
to catch this one on me and i love him
coming down to go make tackles he can do
everything that you want a safety to do
he checks every box he is my he's my
favorite safety in this group i think he
is probably if i go if i'm being
generous to kayvon thibodeaux he's one i
think hamilton's probably two and dean's
probably three for me in this out of my
favorite players no you screw it
hamilton's my favorite player
then dean they're tied for one and one a
and then came on thibodeau but for me
this is an a-plus this is a guy that i
thought should have win in the top five
but the way they value safeties
defensive backs specifically safeties
get screwed even though they're one of
the most important positions in the nfl
nfl scout says everyone who knows him
says he's extremely ambitious but the
ego doesn't match the talent he is
humble richard sherman
what do we think of the top safety going
off the board to the baltimore ravens
and kyle hamilton look at you're smiling
already richard well i i
i i mean because i thought it was going
to be criminal if he slid past 15. you
know i know baltimore is jumping out of
their shoes because they have a great
secondary you know they pride themselves
on their defense and they always have
marlon humphries is coming back as you
mentioned chuck clark is now going to be
the third safety you got marcus williams
coming in i mean they're going to be so
dynamic and so versatile in the
secondary and they're going to need to
be with cincinnati being as dynamic as
they are and continuing to grow they
have three receivers that you have to
deal with so you have to be able to to
come back their versatility and you know
what you you know that desean watson is
now with the cleveland browns so that
division has gotten a lot better and the
ravens have responded
man kyle hamilton the safety going to
the baltimore ravens this is a team that
was beset by injuries last year marcus
peter a season-ending injury humphrey's
season-ending injury if my stats are
correct they were last in the nfl in
passing yards allowed last year and now
they have a guy in the back if they get
healthy multiplicity it is going to be a
new defensive coordinator in mike
mcdonald which will be interesting but
what eric decosta does there is just
draft winners and it looks like he just
drafted one here and the change to
mcdonald won't be
extremely drastic right we see a lot of
teams go through that's a good thing
going wink to him
similar minds yeah they'll be a little
bit consistent
wow okay a lot of excitement here yeah
he's good the guy's good man if you
watch him play like i don't see i don't
care what his 40 time is because he has
this incredible ability to see things
before they happen and that's something
that i love out of a safety and i love
it out of a linebacker when you see
stuff and you know it's going to happen
before it does yes when you call out
plays before they happen when you do all
those little things i don't care what
your 40 time is because you're going to
beat the guy to the spot because you
know where he's going to be all right so
the houston texans are on the clock and
if my mind is correct this was the
eagle's pick that was traded so yes this
was originally the pick that the eagles
got from the dolphins from jalen waddle
houston able to trade back pick up a few
picks early on they went derrick
stingley at three
i feel like this is another place to get
germaine are we just going to be a
broken record at this point or do you
think maybe they go
where do you go you're the expert here
it's a matter of if they want to spread
the resources around right because
you've accepted that you're going into
next season with davis mills and yes you
got an extension done with brandon cooks
but
what in this offense scares you now the
problem is is the answer here right i
like traylin burks a lot i have no
problem i have no problem taking
trailing burks and if you don't get them
now uh you're going to be in big trouble
as the the pick sound goes off in my ear
and it is going to be
our first interior office green
kenyan green
is going to the houston texans
houston texans trade back from 13 to 15
and they take two-time consensus
all-american kenyan green and this man
is versatile yay 6-4 over 320 35 starts
17 at left guard 15 at right guard two
at right tackle one at left tackle and
he has not missed a game in three
seasons going to a team that was last in
rushing 28th in passing and does need
some help along that offensive line
before we get to the player the value
where did you have him ranked on your
big board and does it fit 15. i don't
love it to be honest with you he's my
25th overall player so this isn't
from mars right this isn't taking a
player that's a third round player but
the question here is guys when i watch
kenyon green i love his tape when he's
playing guard i don't love his tape when
he's playing tackle so did you just
draft a guard that's a good prospect
he's not gonna unseat laramie tencel at
left tackle sure definitely questions
about titus howard at right tackle and
their interior is not very good this
team could not run the football last
year now i like kenyon green he's a good
run blocker he's got a lot of power as a
drive blocker once again his pass
protection woes uh can be you know
eliminated on the inside a little more i
think sometimes he had slow feet i think
sometimes he had slow hands i think
sometimes he just didn't cover enough
ground at tackle and pass bro that he
had no problems at guard because he's
got the anchor strength at guard but
once again
you know could they just not get far
enough back
nobody was taking kenyan green in the
top 20 picks 23 picks maybe dallas is
where things started here so for the
texans i just wonder you there's a lot
more valuable players on the board for a
team that's missing blue chip talent
right now if you're gonna if you're
fixated on improving the interior
offensive line i take tyler linderbaum
who's a blue chip talent who's a 10-year
starter probably a pro bowler every year
so this stinks because i like kenyon
green as the player this just feels off
and i don't know how much better the
texans are right now so it's a c-plus
and it's less about kenyan green but
more about the houston texans plan that
i don't understand
yeah i listen this is one of those ones
that's kind of the mind blower where
you're thinking
what is this this is who they wanted to
get is this the guy that they needed to
get so for me listen i'd love to hear
this kind of explain it a little bit
more i'm going to go ahead and i'm going
to give it just a straight up c
i know that some people had zion johnson
listed ahead of him at guard where they
plan to play him will be interesting
because he is so versatile uh our guy
jason kelsey very versatile let's let's
focus on just the player and not the t
and not where he was drafted kelsey what
do you think about this guy when you
watch him
yeah i mean he's a he's
he is a very very good guard and i think
he'll be a very very good guard i think
sometimes in the draft
you know i don't know how the big boards
and you know ranking uh you know the
value goes but i think this kid's going
to be a really really good player now
can he play tackle
you know i think he probably is is going
to be a very good guard and get you out
of a game type of tackle
very physical powerful
uh probably the best people mover at the
guard position you'll see
um you know he's he's a guy that is
going to change the line of scrimmage
keep it firm inside great usage of his
hands i mean he's a very powerful guy
and um you know so for that the houston
texans are going to get a guy that's
going to be able to change the line of
scrimmage and uh be a big difference
difference maker for their offensive
line awesome thank you mr jason kelsey
it also makes sense from the perspective
of nick casario and that patriots uh
they love big offensive lineman this is
a big one from tom pelicero the ravens
have traded wide receiver hollywood
brown and the 100th pick to the
cardinals for the 23rd pick i have been
hearing everyone's been hearing the
cardinals wanted one of these wide
receivers to get out there aj green a
little bit older deandre hopkins was
getting banged up
are we surprised the ravens are moving
hollywood brown he was coming to the end
of his rookie contract we knew that they
was facing an extension i am very
curious let's keep an eye on lamar
jackson's twitter yeah he's not going to
be happy he this is one of his best
friends but hollywood brown he's a
little bit banged up but when he plays
he's great and we have another pick
washington speaking of wide receivers
going with michael felder is one of your
favorite jahan datsun out of penn state
at pick number 16. guys where do we want
to go to first we are ahead of the
broadcast do we want to do a little bit
of hollywood or do we want to just move
on to johan dodson what are we thinking
what's your first reaction when you hear
hollywood brown of the cardinals counter
i mean it obviously fits everything
cliff wants you just want vertical speed
you want big plays
i'm a little confused right now we're
gonna find out more with that 23rd
overall pick
what are the ravens doing offensively
necessarily for lamar jackson let's
focus on this jahaan dodson is going to
washington at pick number 16. washington
was able to move down in their draft
moving to 16 and getting jahan datsun
out of penn state uh i i want to go to
felder first because i know you love
this guy but i want to save it but jahan
dotson third team big ten only had two
drops and 138 targets last year and he
was averaging 24 and a half yards punt
return so he's versatile did you expect
him to go on the top 16 connor no but
you have to be aware of this wide
receiver on that i've been trying to
warn you about i mean he's the 29th
overall player but that doesn't it
doesn't matter right they're just going
off the board we still have trailing
berks there but this is a different kind
of player so
i think when you look at it with johan
dotson right here you're drafting speed
but he is more than that and i know
felder is going to take this thing away
like a runway so i don't want to give it
all away johan dotson he plays bigger
than his size right there you see him
going up and winning the football he's a
playmaker he's got vertical wheels he's
not the shiftiest smaller wide receiver
but can you get down the field can you
get open and obviously run after the
catch these are all things he does
really really well he's got excellent
hands some of the best hands in this
draft and that goes back to the
concentration and tracking the toe
tapping the body control washington they
know they have to put weapons around
carson lentz you have terry mclaren
who's due for an extension now you have
jahan dotson it's a good amount of speed
to complement mclaren so for datsun here
well yes he's a top 30 player but this
is a little early you don't get hung up
on that because this helps the
quarterback that you traded for so this
is a b for me for washington can't wait
to hear this one yeah this guy smells
the end zone and that's the big thing
about the clips we just watched any time
he gets that ball inside the tin inside
the five he's going to make somebody
miss make another guy miss and he's
going to get to the end zone love his
ability to contort his body and i love
the fact that he knows when he's gonna
be open i think ham and sean clifford
had a beautiful thing going to penn
state uh because listen 91 catches he's
the guy he's going to be the guy in the
fact that everyone knew he was the guy
and he still caught the football means
that he understands how to get open uh
for me with jahan dotson i'm gonna go
ahead and i'm gonna
do it this is i
this is rough
but i'm gonna give it an a i like this
player so much and this for me is less
about where he's picked and more about
genuinely believing that this guy is an
amazing wide receiver i don't know if
he's in the top five group i think
burke's probably still should come off
the board should have come off the board
before him but when you get a guy like
this that's gonna step in and be an
earner i love that ability that he
brings to the table and just watching
him play week over week he kept
delivering even when teams knew what was
coming
okay so washington comes back from 11 to
16 trey with the sick with the saints
and they take datsun a monroe st brown
uh watching datsun on tape what stuck
out to you
uh i think he's a sure receiver uh i
wasn't this pick actually surprised me i
didn't think you'd go this high but
watching his tape like i said about a
lot he reminds me a little bit about a
lava smooth receiver great hands can do
a lot of things i think him with terry
mclaurin is going to be very
very good for carson wentz those are two
you know players that can do almost
everything they can run the short route
they can run the deep route they're
almost going to catch everything you
watch terry go up and make those crazy
grabs johan reminds me a lot of that
making those crazy grabs you still have
one hand catch you out against um ohio
state i believe so i mean you watch a
guy like you have those two guys on the
field at the same time it's going to be
pretty dangerous i think so i really
like this pick i didn't think he'd go
this early but i like it and you're
seeing these clips right here he had 21
career touchdowns 10 of them were 40
plus yards he gets the ball in his hands
and he is
gone jahan dodson the pick for
washington at 16. let's keep on monroe
st brown on one more time amman
your reaction to hollywood brown getting
traded to the cardinals how do you think
that's going over in the ravens locker
room and what do you think about him
with arizona
yeah i know you like you said earlier i
think lamar jackson isn't happy about
that but i think for arizona that's a
it's a good move um they just got rid of
christian kirk he signed with the
jaguars
so hollywood brown being able to add
some speed to that receiver room
obviously they have aj greens getting a
little bit older like you said
d-hop um but i think hollywood brown's
gonna take the top off the defense so
you could put him in the slot you can
move him out wide you can move around so
i think for the cardinal that's a good
it's a good move um
i'm not so sure about the ravens though
yeah it's gonna be very that's my
question right now yeah where where are
we going thank you
and you you never want to you know kill
a plan before you you want to see it
completely unraveled but for me i've
been saying for a while baltimore felt
like a sleeper team to take a wide
receiver in the top 15 because
look at the afc right now everybody when
you think you got enough weapons you
take two more you keep going everyone's
trying to have three to four dynamic
weapons so i thought baltimore might
follow that playbook instead they traded
one of their weapons so now what happens
now and man pick 23 feels like a mile
away when you're looking at this wide
receiver board absolutely you guys i i
can't believe we've gotten this far we
haven't discussed a thing that as a
college football analyst
this is hold the pick finish your point
this is who kyler murray was throwing
the ball to when his first season of
starting
talk on it this is who they they they're
a match made in heaven this is it's a
similar offense to what he played in
oklahoma right it's gonna be the guy
that he's used to throwing the football
to all they would have to do now is what
trade for cd lamb and they'd have the
whole entire office put back together
not a bad idea how's i was like are we
not going to talk about this part of it
we're talking about the ravens but look
look at what just happened so do you
think in a weird way hollywood's like oh
no oh wait that's all my guys yeah
that's kyler that's cliff i got my guy
i'm good i'm gonna be good like cliff is
he cliff's not lincoln riley
but he's close enough yeah
uh 17. another guard comes off the board
chargers taking boston college guard
zion johnson so a mini interior
offensive lineman run happening right
now
the justin herbert era you gotta protect
the guy they went out there and they
invested in wide receivers and they made
sure that you know justin herbert got
mike williams back but it's 6-3 312 zion
johnson the number one guard on a number
of people's board 17 connor the value of
zion johnson see i like this one a
little better and i know that sounds
crazy when you look at it but just for
where the chargers are at as a franchise
compared to the texans so zion from east
27th which is behind two spots behind
kenyan green okay but the chargers
needed offensive line help he reminded
me of ali marpett while watching him the
highly highly athletic player he started
at left tackle he started at left guard
odd transition to be a left guard then a
left tackle the next year and then back
to left guard you don't see that a lot
in college at the senior bowl when i was
down there he even snapped the ball took
snaps at center wow he's gonna play
guard very versatile guy uh incredible
guy to bring into your locker room one
of the biggest high floor players in
this draft because of the athleticism
because of the ability to move people in
the run game he's very reliable on the
inside as a pass protector so for zion
johnson this is a big help for justin
herbert and it's a high floor player the
value i would have went trent mcduffie
here instead that's my only little gripe
i would have really liked that fit yes
but it's just a rock solid b this kind
of pick for your offensive line you were
just saying 58 straight games didn't
miss 26 at left guard 13 a left tackle
10 at right tackle and what's
interesting is they had matt filer down
there at left guard this is a guy that
has played when he was with the steelers
tackle as well so in a way you get to
move him to tackle knock out storm
norton and now you could put in zion
johnson and now the interior offensive
line is looking good for justin herbert
yeah i mean this is i'm going to go i'm
going to go ahead and go b-plus this is
a guy that's a little feels a little
early but the reality is he's a really
good football player and he's coming
from i know we talk about it with iowa
but bc they got their own in wisconsin
as well bc's got their own little
offensive line found going too he is
currently working towards his masters in
cyber security policy and governance
look at the big brain on zion what
all right don't do it yet jason kelsey
your thoughts on zion johnson the fact
that he's gonna be blocking for uh
justin herbert what do you think of this
guy
yeah i mean i think it's a great pick
this kid is incredibly athletic freaky
athletic
moves people can uh can do zone or power
schemes
uh it's kind of a tweener
from guard or center i kind of like them
at center but with corey linsley there
he'll fit in nicely guard i mean he's a
he's a very solid player then you just
touched on you can see you can see how
smart he is even just in the tape he's
the guy that gets it his coach liked him
so much he brought him with them to
boston college from davidson right um
you know this kid's got a lot of a lot
of great traits uh that uh you know
they're gonna love them hey kelsey
stay on the line with me because the
eagles are up and apparently there's a
trade and they're not telling me what it
is so we're going to find this out
together oh my god yeah
do you see that
do you see that
hey brown they traded for aj brown [ __ ]
it out of the way get out of the way
kelsey said down we're looking at your
belly big left go
this is big
the eagles just how about that one 18th
pick and a third round pick for one of
the best young wide receivers in the nfl
aj brown jason kelsey what is going on
right now what is going on right now
dude
howie howie roseman is working that
highly roseman magic that's what's going
on
he's swindling he's he's moving up in
the draft to get jordan davis and now
he's trading to get an unbelievable
receiver
uh this is i'm like on christmas right
now jason remember when you're
saying this after the super bowl and you
were like howie roseman was in a hallway
closet and now he's out here trading for
aj brown jason they knew jason they said
we need to bring jason kelsey out of
retirement you're not leaving we're
gonna pay you 14 million and now they're
giving you aj brown bro aj brown
yeah this is huge this is instantly an
upgrade for the offense i mean i can't
tell you how much this is gonna make us
better
uh howie is uh he's the man on a mission
right now man he's making things happen
and uh
uh i'm a big fan here we go baby wow
there we go
wow this has turned into one of the best
nights of my life incredible value too i
mean you trade 18. third rounder for aj
brown like i'm sitting here going maybe
they go trailing berks and i'm like man
maybe hopefully one day he could become
half of what aj brown is
let's look at the eagles room and see
what the eagles room is saying right now
you have gotta be s in me let's effing
go
real s y'all lfg howie is redeeming
himself big time this year
ah
aj brown
aj brown
what are you guys gonna win the super
bowl this year no
but you'll enjoy watching but this is a
guy that you go the dream is to take
somebody like this always round yeah and
not only that
so he's coming up on a contract
extension
him and devonta smith
yeah guys
tell am i being too much no i mean this
is electric this is an awesome trade i
mean besides here's the craziest thing
to me in all of this yes you got to pay
him what's good for them yes you're
going to have to you got to pay him to
keep yeah you got to pay it's 18. no i
agree he's somebody that you i i'm kind
of confused how we got here with
tennessee and i hate to always be the
guy that looks at the other side
i mean sure but once you just said it
left go if everything goes right with
trailing bursts who i like a lot it's
what this is we're talking about
something in two or three years yeah and
then he's aj brown they are very similar
play styles
so for me eagles i mean a plus plus plus
i just don't understand what this
tennessee offense is right now and i
mean obviously we're gonna get some
answers here
but man you were you were the number one
seed in the afc
what are you now
and they are taking
traelin burks so they said oh you want a
new contract extension because devante
adams and tyree kill just changed the
market well we're gonna go out and we're
gonna take hopefully a younger version
that we can get on a five-year deal
and that we're not gonna have to pay
and he is a big dude six two two twenty
five run a four or five he's at 40.
treylen burks and you know this this was
my favorite wide receiver in this draft
class set the school record with six 100
yard receiving games and he is a warrior
in the workout room benches 380 squats
500
power cleans 320 but they had to give up
aj brown to get it
factoring that in what do we think of
that at 18. when you factor that in it's
tough because you lost a great player
that you should have paid we can't get
out of the way but for me i i want to
talk about treylin burks because this is
his moment and i don't want that to get
lost right here when you look at
berkshire me obviously 14th overall
player he's awesome and i'm so tired of
hearing he's a big slaughter you have to
make things simple for him he's on the
outside in the sec mossing cornerback so
i don't know what we're missing there
455 at 230 pounds is much different than
4-4 at 180 pounds i think people need to
understand size speed build up speed
breaking tackles with the ball in your
hands he is an old school player for me
i wrote my scouting port a backyard
brawler just looking to out-muscle
everyone and he can you can get him
pitch passes you can get him screens you
can motion him out of the backfield and
just throw shallow crossers to him but
down the field he can win the ball
vertically as well so you lose aj brown
and i don't like this trade at all i
cannot emphasize that enough but this is
traylin burks's just his pick i love the
player a top 15 player for me i'm very
high on him i do think there is a place
where berks can become an aj brown kind
of player so i will factor in the trade
in the grade love the player hate the
trade it's a b for me right in the
middle
here's the thing and i'll be quick
this guy's a football player that plays
wide receiver and that means a lot to me
yeah you love that he's a football
player that plays wide receiver he did
anything and everything that arkansas
asked him to do and i don't care about
the trade that's not my job my job is my
job my only job listen i don't work in
the nfl baby i don't cover it my i only
talk about college football players and
for me burks is up there as someone who
i find to be remarkably special
for what he excuse me i'll get choked up
i'm gonna start crying i don't [ __ ]
get this i love this i love this guy
he's so good for real like he is he
means a lot to me to watch him play and
i was doing radio in arkansas and i did
get teary eyed talking about what he
meant to that program because they love
him i'm going to go with an a here
because you're getting the guy that we
thought was going to be would probably
come off the board in the top 15
and you're getting them i know you had
to give up something to get them but
you're getting them at 18 and you're
getting someone who is going to bring we
don't often talk about wide receivers as
tone setters in a locker room but he's
someone that's going to make everybody
around him want to play harder last year
he had 22 plays of 20 or more yards he
is explosive he ran away from alabama
which is hard to do yeah a monroe st
brown let's bring him in here this is
not your kind of wide receiver this is
uh this is a what do you think when you
watch this dude on tape were you just
shocked at how big and fast he was
yeah i mean he's a big body it's kind of
ironic that the tides made that trade it
almost seems like they're trying to get
that same player with trailing burks um
but no watching his tape he reminds me a
little of a aj brown slash little debo
in him you know you get the ball in his
hands and he's hard to bring down he
runs a 4-5 but like you said that size
and speed combination is insane
so he does have that debo asking him to
me just because when you get that ball
in his hands he's making guys miss he's
breaking tackles and once he's gone no
one's catching so
i
love the pick um i don't know about the
trade but i love the pick um i think
he's gonna do great in the league can
play inside outside throw him a bubble
screen reverse just get the bonus hand
he's going to make it play
thank you very much to monroe st brown
it is indeed the titans who take traelin
berks and he does
fit the style of how they like their
players also they went out there this
offseason they they got robert woods uh
it's a nice compliment to traelin burks
out there in the all-white and i i want
to emphasize something that connor just
said
let us not hold the weight of this trade
over this kid right away not fair what
will happen unfortunately for the next
few years is he will be compared to aj
brown
it's going to be tough he's built for it
and he is built for it this is a dude
that had big time offers and stayed home
and went to a razorbacks program that
was in the dumpster and when he walked
out of there they look a lot better he's
built to the soil good luck traelyn
burks all right are you loving this
draft coverage in the palm of your hand
that's your cell phone our show is
sponsored by rocket mortgage they've
also made it possible for you to get a
home loan right here
on your phone with a process built
around your needs when you need a home
loan that fits you rocket can just like
the eagles can completely change the
entire fortunes of their franchise in
one day trading for jordan davis and
then also finding a way to get aj
freaking
brown speaking of
oh
and we're gonna pay you right away
four years a hundred million fifty-seven
guaranteed we don't have to worry if
you're gonna get that check cause the
eagles got the green the eagles got the
green what can brown do for you
hopefully win you a super bowl the
eagles just got the biggest baddest
defensive lineman and aj brown
i
i'm good
i'm real good
i'm just we got later
[Laughter]
he's paid now yeah so we don't even have
to worry about that discussion doesn't
even exist it doesn't even exist can i
take it one step further go for it he
has the same representation as dk
metcalf and debo samuel so those teams
are on the clock it's pay time they just
set the line for here's the line
and dk mech after bringing they got
better numbers and debo's going mine i
do more than him
wow
so wow get ready i don't think we're
done here you know what's so incredible
and i i know we're gonna have to get
ready to start doing the saints second
pick but um
i just wanted to say that i thought we
were gonna have to find a young guy and
that it was gonna go well jalen hurts is
gonna have to prove it and we're
drafting it for the next guy yeah aj
brown
can erase a lot of wood i just think
about him coming out of ole miss
compared to all these wide receivers and
i would have taken aj brown over all
these wide receivers all of the ones in
this draft i mean i'm a little crazy now
i'm so biased now
well cause you know what he is yeah
let's not forget aj brown was a second
round pick and we liked him okay
all right i've done enough talking
you're doing great it's like wait what i
i like the left go uh riding high right
now it's a good draft change i've been a
part of the derek barnett i've been part
of well during the process
last year was devante smith and now this
and
yeah okay new orleans saints are on the
clock they were at 11. well they traded
up to 11 to take chris olave they
answered that what are they doing now
trevor penning so they do get their
linemen but i want to say this you were
worried that they were going to take him
at 11 but instead they wait and they
take him at 19. well i was terrified
they were going to take him at 11. i was
cautious but expected this to be the
second northern iowa's trevor penning 33
starts 31 of them at left tackle which
is likely where he is going to slide
right in to replace the one and only
tehran armstead who went down to miami
value first i get the sense you didn't
have him going in the top 20. he's my
47th overall player
and i knew he was going in the first
round this isn't a surprise for me i
just have some questions here when you
look at trevor penning right you're
coming out of the fcs felder likes to
say you're graduating two levels that is
real so you're coming out of the fcs
he's a dynamic athlete he's a special
athlete for the position you turn on
that all 22 and the fcs tape and he's on
the ground a lot he's on the ground a
lot and i watched him with another
offensive line coach
in the nfl and it's a constant throwing
the punch while your feet are leaving
the ground and that's how you end up on
the ground a lot in passpro and man if
that's happening in the fcs it is going
to be an a rude awakening at the nfl
level so i like penning's athleticism i
think he's nasty in the run game but i
think penalties are an issue i think his
pass protection needs serious refinement
he's not a young prospect he's not a
tyler smith that's 20 years old on draft
day he's going to be a 23 year old
on draft day right now so he's a guy
that it's not old but i'm just saying
he's played a lot a lot of college
football he's gotten a lot better from
their spring season all the way to this
last fall season but i don't this is a
project tackle to me and for some reason
the nfl views him as a surefire answer
to start from day one i don't agree with
that i think it's not going to be fair
to his development i think it's not
going to be good for the quarterback
situation there so this is a c for me
trevor penning's got a long ways to go
he broke the school's squat record did
625 and have all the offensive linemen
at the combine fastest 10 and 20-yard
splits the athleticism he's great
athlete he's a great athlete what do you
think athleticism he seems like a
grabber and i guess
yes but he seems like a grabber right
and there's a lot when you're the you're
the biggest and strongest guy and you
have the ability to kind of get a tight
grab and throw that's one thing but a
lot of wood i'd love to see a little bit
more drive but listen i'm gonna give it
a b minus i'm very curious to hear what
kelsey thinks because obviously he's our
expert yes and yeah jason you we're
talking about grabbing we're talking
about technique and athleticism
you look at the film of this kid what do
you see
the same thing conor michael just said i
mean this kid
has all the tools he's physical he's big
uh but he is very unrefined um
you know he is a big thrower he is a big
grabber uh he is a big uh you know like
block around guys i mean and he has the
tools to to not do that that's what's
frustrating like this guy can be really
good and it's evident um you know he
turns a lot in in pass pro which worries
me
you know and usually that happens with
unathletic guys that can't get off the
ball you know they can't keep guys in
front of them so they have to turn
but this dude's a freak so i don't i
mean maybe it's just the way they coach
guys down there uh maybe if he gets the
right coach on him
he can stop doing stuff like that which
looks good on tape
but ultimately leads to holding calls
and um unfortunately uh you know some
negative plays can happen all right we
will see if they can develop him down
there in new orleans jason are you have
you spent any more time thinking about
your new teammate agent brown i'm i mean
this is insane
i mean dude my phone is blowing up i
can't i'm like having trouble staying
on track right now because i'm just
answering text non-style have you got
any text from like teammates he's got
the best
the the state of the eagles right now
are you guys just like teammates family
friends everybody
everybody everybody's shocked that this
happened
i'm telling you man howie uh when he i
mean he is always ready to make
something happen yeah
i mean we just got one of the best deep
ball receivers in the nfl give him a
kiss on the forehead i mean the next
time you see him
my brother just texted me and said bro
you guys just got the biggest cheat code
in the nfl oh so yeah i think i'm
feeling pretty good about this move
amazing
all right brother i'll i'll let you go
answer your texts steelers are up at 20
but i'm looking at the big board right
now well
and the elephant in the room the
elephant in the room is uh jermaine
johnson no they have malik willow
they've loved malik willis since the
senior bowl mm-hmm we've heard some a
little buzz recently about catty pickett
elephant in the room of the guy that's
still yeah no you're absolutely right
the jermaine i said linda bomb i thought
is gonna go to round two so that's not a
surprise jermaine johnson i am i am
caught off guard by this but i am
fascinated by the steelers right now
do you think they go malik i do i think
that they were they never wanted to pay
assets to go up for a quarterback in
this class but you sit there at 20 and
you go cool here we go
kenny picks he went quarterback
can he pick it
so practically working out in the
steelers facility
but not the quarterback that i think we
all thought it would be
the pit quarterback is staying in
pittsburgh kenny pickett will now be the
new face of the pittsburgh steelers a
42-7 touchdown interception ratio
and you're gonna have to get your hands
on this because kenny's might be too
small uh eight and a half inches sorry i
didn't mean to do that right away but
pittsburgh steelers they go with kenny
pickett where did you have them ranked
are you surprised this is the
quarterback they go with no there were
there were a lot of buzz about both
right malik was the senior bull guy they
were all over him there but there was a
lot of recent buzz about kenny pickett
they obviously have been all over the
quarterbacks in this class didn't want
to go up and get one which is they
really knew how the board was going to
play which is a really good job and they
have a lot of smart football people
besides the people at the top like
brandon hunt in that building as well so
i look at it like this right is this a
good quarterback class absolutely not is
pickett a high floor player i think at
his best he's a derek carr level player
which would be really good if that's
what you come away with i think he's a
late breakout player 24 year old rookie
played a lot of college ball at pitt i
think he throws with anticipation i
think he does a good job getting through
his reads he has enough athleticism to
play in this modern day nfl and he goes
into a situation where
a lot of people thought he'd be the guy
drafted forced to start he's going into
a situation where they are going to roll
with mitch trubisky yes unless we see a
kenny pickett mac jones s summer where
it's like no we we have to play this guy
so i love the landing spot for pickett
the value's not that far off they sat at
20. he's 32nd on my board do i ever
think kenny pickett will be a superstar
in the afc like mahomes josh allen joe
burrow i don't but i think the steelers
do a really good job building an
infrastructure for quarterbacks to
develop and thrive so this is a b for me
i like that they didn't give up future
assets to go get him and i do think he
can be a long-term starter
this is the new face after big ben era
felder
it feels safe
um and obviously the steeler the
steelers tend to like safe
he's a really good football player i
mean i think he's super athletic there
was a time in his career where he was
running back and forth to the sideline
to get plays like old school high school
football style and watching him develop
over the course of his junior year in
high school all the way through his
senior year of college every single year
every step of the way he's gotten better
when i saw him in 2016 in dc he was the
guy that was committed to temple and i
thought he was going to be really good
at temple and then he gets better gets
the pit offer then he gets better ends
up at obviously at pitt playing really
well you throw in mark whipple whipple
he's an nfl offensive coordinator yes he
comes in wet ready to compete willing to
compete i know the hands thing is
something that people bring up his
interception or excuse me his fumble
rate yep is below the average fumble
rate for quarterbacks so even though he
has 38 career fumbles the rate of it is
low his his senior year race is lower
yeah it's just big which is but that's
the thing earlier in his career earlier
in his career more of a problem then
later in his career which goes back to
what i said he's improved every single
step of the way yes and then comes
coming from an nfl offense i think this
helps for me
the big thing that connor brought up was
that he doesn't have to play right now
so if he doesn't have to play right now
why don't you get the guy that's going
to be better so i'm going to go i'm
going to go with c-plus
who would you have gone here malik
willis
if you don't have to play right now
go with the higher ceilings go with the
guy that i can teach to be better
it is interesting though i mean this man
passed dan marino's stats at pitt and it
goes back to da
the pittsburgh steelers had a chance to
take dan marino and they didn't do it at
pitt and now this guy we watched all
those highlights yeah and they're all in
the same football field yeah and there's
something about familiarity and having
all that around there but the new face
of the pittsburgh steelers was the face
of pittsburgh in college pretty cool
kenny pickett's the guy yeah shocking
though are you guys shocked right now uh
no i had him as the first quarterback
off the board i did hear about that too
i don't bet um
i heard that
uh i heard late that this had picked up
steam and you get sucked into things
right when you're at the senior bowl
there you see mike tomlin talking to the
family you see him talking to malik not
pickett talking to malik willis
you become a little biased oh i saw that
and so i think not shocked we knew they
were in on quarterbacks and i did think
pick it would be the first one off the
board i i just thought it would be a
little earlier than this how does he do
so it'll be a nazi harris center team
chase claypole will be out there good
possession guy they did go out there and
they invested in the offensive line this
offseason which made me excited uh mason
colette center and james daniels from
chicago who i think we all liked coming
out of iowa maybe wasn't as great with
the bears but um is this also the kind
of guy that matt canada he can run
because he is mobile enough we saw it in
the bowl game that move he's got wheels
you can get him outside the pocket and
cut the field in half which is great for
rookie quarterbacks right you're
simplifying things you're creating
levels on the football field you have
your underneath guy you have your
vertical guy that carries the corner and
you have your intermediate target he
does a good job going one two three
right and getting the ball out that's
what kenny pickett can do now once again
it goes back to what felder said
and what i believe in this league right
now special players are going deep into
the playoffs and you have to build you
know can you replicate what the niners
did right where
jimmy wasn't driving the truck he was
along for the ride because that roster
was special 21 patriots pick is in my
first guess before we show it don't show
it yet i just want to guess yeah i don't
know it uh my guess is going to be trent
mcduffie just because they have some
holes at cornerback who would your guest
i would go with devin lloyd he fits
their linebacker profile oh wow you're
absolutely right what do you think
it's going with my heart what's your
heart in the kobe dean nicolby should
make me really because listen man when
the patriots get a linebacker you're
like he's going to be good let's see
what the pick is the pick is in yes and
the pick is
wow nice left go all right
well done i got that one trent mcduffie
they lost jc jackson he went out there
to the chargers they did add malcolm
butler they did add terence mitchell but
they go out the patriots do and they get
the corner from washington that a lot of
people thought could go even in the top
ten trent mcduffie first team all pac-12
was a track star in high school from the
hundred meters to the four by one
hundred and he has return ability which
you know belichick loves trent mcduffie
corner off the board here at pick number
21 where did you expect him to go i
expect him to go earlier than this i
thought he would be a top 17 pick
because of the chargers there now this
fits like a glove
type of guy belichick likes i stood in
front of his podium at the combine uh
honestly i think he's the smartest
football player in the entire nfl draft
oh my god belgium i think that he just
lives all he does is he when he's a
captain i i think he yeah he was a team
captain he was the leader of that
defensive back room
um
what do we think premature the pats
train it out
sickos they pulled the rug out wow
everything was going so smooth wow so
they traded out okay false alarm
the patriots have changed to the chiefs
okay so all of that
wow let me erase the pick might still be
mcduffie in this situation they need a
corner the chiefs do need a corner at
the same point they could also be going
for the falling knife which is jermaine
johnson because they do need a pass
rusher yes outside of frank clark they
also needed a wide receiver are there
any wide receivers that you trade up for
here
maybe a skye moore maybe a pickens i
don't think you need to trade up for
that though uh that would be something
they don't need a linebacker but yeah if
jermaine johnson or trent mcduffie would
be maybe the pick there i doubt you
trade up for a car loftus
no i don't think he's gonna this is
what's your pick guess i i still think
mcduffie i think the the value is there
so maybe they saw mcduffie's name being
etched on the jersey thought it was
patriot or they saw it in the system
yeah this is the chiefs yeah that would
make sense too that's how you get played
you just see the pick come in and yeah
you guessed it don't know which team it
is yeah you guess
the people that leak these picks
obviously have the nfl's fax system yes
they get the picks facts because we live
in 1948 or whatever in the nfl
so that could have happened as well and
so we'll wait to see the details of
which kansas city pick they traded
whether it was 29 or 30. i have a hard
time thinking that they would trade 29
and let the patriots be ahead of them
but we'll see what the deal is
yeah
i didn't even think about that but i was
like yeah they do a back to back all
right so cam behind is instead man uh
yeah so we're we're all still thinking
it's mcduffie and if it if it is do you
like that pick oh yeah i would i would
love it uh it was my you know cb2 in
this draft you see him uh 15th overall
they did they did it they did he gave up
29.
interesting so they gave up 29 so the
patriots will have the pick right in
front of kansas city which is
interesting because they do share a few
needs but i'm sure belichick weighed all
of that in uh when he made this trade so
we are still waiting to see what it is
it's mcduffie it is yeah yeah it's
making all right let's do the video
there we go um
kansas city they make this election
with a trade to get up to 21 with the
new england patriots we knew that they
had a lead at a need at cornerback and
it is going to be trent mcduffie they
lost their best cornerback this
offseason in charvarius ward to the san
francisco 49ers signed a contract over
40 million dollars and the chiefs like
to play spagnolo does four cornerback
schemes and so it is going to be trent
mcduffie the pick for the chiefs here at
21 brett veach making a move
with andy
with bill belichick to get this done a
cornerback that has a lot of speed and a
lot of versatility what do you think of
the chiefs taking mcduffie here at 21. i
mean i still love it you're talking
about a contender getting one of the
best players in this draft 15th overall
player for me kind of a blend of the
player reminds me a little bit of logan
ryan reminds me a little bit of gyre
alexander a smaller corner he will come
into the nfl i think with the shortest
arms for a corner it doesn't matter
excellent tackler excellent instincts uh
incredibly intelligent guy they're also
trying to replace honey badger right now
too so
he loves he was always asking his
coaches can i play safety can i play
safety like you're too good of a corner
he likes to come down the alley tackle
he's got great instincts it goes back to
what i said earlier plant and drive come
down he'll make a play on the football
if you can't get there in time to make a
play on the football make the tackle do
not give up any extra yards that's the
name of the league right now how
offenses are running he's excellent in
that regard he is ready to play he's a
good athlete he is the mental makeup in
my opinion of a 10-year nfl veteran
which you get maybe one or two of those
guys in every nfl draft that's mcduffie
this is an a for me i like the chiefs
being aggressive to go get my corner
back too and one of the best defenders
in this entire draft what do you think
felder yeah i love it the kid's good and
this is the thing we talked about sauce
we talked about stingley right the two
guys that come off in the top with the
top five yeah and those guys are we call
them man corners consistently this is a
guy that's not a band corner you
mentioned him wanting to play safety i
give this an a because when you look at
what he's able to do he is someone that
can play we watched him on the clip we
watched him track across the field in
man so you can play him in the slot have
him run with a slot across the field in
man you can play him outside and let him
be a guy in cloud in that cover too yes
that's going to help force the edge you
can play him again you could play him
over the top and press you can play him
inside and press he's going to be able
to mirror that slot foot to foot and
then carry him up the field he can do a
lot of different things and the chiefs
love to play that multiple defense where
the roles are constantly changing
richard sherman you think of the chiefs
and you think about trent mcduffie what
kind of a fit do we have here at corner
i mean when they lost tarvarius ward i
kind of expected them to to try to get
move up in the draft and maybe get
involved in and trying to get stingley
or r sauce but you know i knew that was
a long shot i think trent mcduffie fits
what they want to do a lot of man-to-man
obviously he plays a lot of off but he's
a great tackler very physical very
feisty you know you can understand what
they see in him and he can be versatile
he can go inside he can go outside you
you have the conversation about him
moving to safety and i think that's what
they see in him they see a guy who's a
football player he plays corner but he
can tackle he has no fear he he moves
well in space he tackles well he's smart
i i expect him to find a way to put him
on the field his rookie year awesome
richard sherman one of the goats thank
you very much yeah i'm just sitting here
and i'm going when they lost honey
badger
the chiefs are about
guys that can do a lot of things yes and
the way that you're talking about trey
mcduffie he kind of covers both but
they're going to need depth
we are now to pick number 22. before we
announce the pick it is the packers we
know that they need to get aaron rodgers
a receiver i don't know if there's any
receivers got it
i'm pretty floored by this where i'm
almost questioning if this source is
right but i'll say it well they're going
to zoom in on the screen
do you what yeah i don't care if you're
wrong you're wrong whatever
kway walker is who i've been texted quay
walker new member of the pack
i think packers fans are guys furious
wow
i think way
walker
quay
walker
linebacker
out of georgia
i don't know if he's the best linebacker
out of georgia quay walker is going to
the green bay packers uh you look at
their linebacker room right now they did
lose i'm kind of shocked i'm just going
to let you go where did you have quay
walker expected to go and what do you
think of this value so
uh somebody i know sprinkled a couple
bucks on him at plus 1000 to be the
first linebacker taken wow um because
this was really picking up over the last
week now
i'm a little floored that still he was
taken before devin lloyd yeah and taken
before his teammate the kobe dean here's
the scoop with koi walker right
big fast athletic range instincts yeah
taking on contact
not great yet he's still a little bit of
a project player for this kind of pick
in the second round you can live with
those things because he's athletic in
space but once again is he this big
bruiser coming downhill
listen he's had a lot of space to run
around because all the guys he's playing
where they're getting drafted tonight
and the other one jaylen carter will be
drafted in the top five in the future so
i have some questions about the value
with this pick when you look at clay
walker as i try to even find him on the
board it just feels like the packers had
other needs in this spot
he's my 74th overall player and they
take him here at 22 with the pick that
they got in the devonta adams trade and
i thought there was a chance he could
sneak in the back end of round one with
the lions picking at the last pick of
this draft and i get your betting on the
athlete i compared them to logan wilson
the bengals linebacker but once again i
don't really like the value here i don't
really like how much better this makes
the packers right now and i don't know
if another team was really going to take
him before their next pick at 28. so
i got to be honest this is really harsh
and this isn't the fun part
this is a d-plus the value's terrible
it's terrible
they have aaron rodgers to win a super
bowl right now quay walker is what's
getting you over the hump that's what
this comes down to sometimes it's that
simple i don't get it no i don't i don't
understand like he needs help aaron
rodgers speak to every he needs help he
needs help to do like for all the antics
and every all the other garbage
he's one of the best quarterbacks in the
nfl and he needs help and this doesn't
help him but guys kway walker played a
lot of special team snaps isn't that
valuable
you know what on day three
i've i've just been on saturday i'm
going i'm going if i'm going dee like i
don't get it because he's not the best
he's not the best linebacker out of that
linebacking room at georgia he's not the
best linebacker uh he's not the best
even that i'm just talking about in the
draft not even other guys that aren't
even in the draft as you mentioned jayla
carter he's not that he's he's not an
edge rusher
which is what we talked about where take
the football away from the quarterback
or find ways to help your quarterback so
he's not that he's a guy that's a side
to side chase linebacker but he's not in
the same world of guys that we've seen
get drafted in the first round as a
chasing linebacker and he's not in that
same world so for me i just don't get
the
i mean i guess all it takes is one team
to fall in love with the player and i'm
i'm with you on that point that why
didn't they just wait to get him at 28.
and it still would have been bad but it
would have been better kway walker the
pick at
22. so the ravens traded hollywood brown
to 22. four excuse me for the 23rd pick
the bills now
trade to jump ahead of the cowboys
from 25 to 23 so the ravens in their
trading of hollywood brown picks up
another was that fourth round pick 130
what are you thinking here felder i'm
trying to do the math in my head and
it's just not working out for me and
someone explained what happened i would
like daxton hill in this spot for
buffalo or buffalo because buffalo has a
little bit of a safety issue right now
obviously and jackson hill can play the
slot for you if you do figure out your
safety issue as well but if not he's
your safety of the future he's a dynamic
athlete he's got ball skills he tackles
he's got incredible eyes and in that
defense you have to be able to see
everything that's what they're going to
ask of you so
i would think this is a move for jackson
hill and if it is it's one of my
favorite picks of the draft i think this
is a would be a slam dunk for buffalo i
haven't met 23 so this is the exact
value but the scheme fit and getting
over the you need match-up players if
you're buffalo who do you see in the big
games why why trade ahead of the cowboys
who do we think maybe that the cowboys
would also share interest in here that
you need to make this move
jermaine johnson could be in play here
that's what i was going to say yeah i
mean he just gave von miller 100 million
dollars
um so that's interesting so i i think i
have the pick um and you're right a
little surprising okay i'm hearing that
it's for cair elam
kair elam is the pick is he right show
us kyuurilum
i'm on fire family feud kyle
the cornerback out of florida which
makes a lot of sense the buffalo bills
trade up two picks to take kyr elam
a first team all sec a year ago
uh his father and his uncle play the nfl
abe and matt high character guy cairo
makes sense from this levi wallace left
in free agency tredavius white tours acl
late in the year and buffalo thinks they
can make a super bowl run and they need
to get talent at corner how talented is
this guy i like kyrie i'm a lot and i
know i have him 35th but you know we're
going to hit a plateau of range of
players for me with kyrie elm here's
what stood out i came out of summer
watching 2020 tape and i said his 2020
tape is right there with derek stingley
why is nobody talking about this guy
unfortunately in 2021 florida program
yeah kylum
sometimes that happens in college it
does you know
coaching problems a lot of different
problems going on guys getting checked
out i don't think kyrie is checked out
let me just break down the exact player
of what he is right you have a big
physical press corner very physical
before the catch point he likes to get
hands on you at the line of scrimmage he
can play off he can turn and run he ran
really well at the combine you see the
play speed on tape the biggest problem i
have with kyrie on that is
non-negotiable for me and i usually
don't care as much about this but you're
taking him this early it matters he
cannot tackle right now and it's
he's built to tackle he is in a family
full of they say matt was popping he was
filling this family full of safeties i
don't even think the effort's that bad
he just struggles to come to balance he
comes down a little too aggressive at
times so maybe it's coachable with him
but in coverage i love the upside of
kyrie ellen the bills they need players
like this because you're seeing jamar
chase and t higgins on the same field we
know what they're going to run into so
uh for me with kyrie ilham the value's
fine because once again the cornerback
run got a little crazy going up to get
him is a little interesting to me i
don't know if i love that but you didn't
really pay anything so overall this is
just a b for me it does make the bills a
lot better you got a corner before this
thing falls off a clip uh cliff and elam
just has a couple technique things to
work on yeah
i think the technique thing is is key
because he's got to clean it up he
cannot be that grabby in the nfl he
lived on grabs he lived on grabbing
people lived on manhandling guys
essentially and whether it was in press
or off he he really he the play for him
doesn't start a lot of times and this is
not indicative of that right he was that
was a bad toss but for a lot of him a
lot of times the play room doesn't start
until he puts hands on somebody this is
one of his tackles that he's able to
make but i love i love the fact that
when he the play starts for him most of
the time when he gets hands on somebody
whether it's for a pbu or if he's
playing press his ability to essentially
stop the route you see him there push
the receiver in the back to create his
own separation run the route for him so
for me i'm gonna go with an a minus
because he's a player that i really like
it's a defensive back that i really like
you mentioned some of the woes they've
had in that back end specifically at the
cornerback spot yeah so they are
addressing a specific need so i
understand it and i'm glad that you
mentioned that it sort of plateaus right
there's not a huge gap between player
number two 35 and 25 yeah 25 and 35
there's not that big of a gap for these
guys
6-1-191 the things that pop out 439
speed and he's not even 21 yet so they
got to be thinking we can groom this guy
uh richard sherman when you're looking
at kair elam and you think about the
buffalo bills how do you think this fits
and what do you think of the prospect
well i mean they got a great set of
safeties with jordan poyer and micah
hyde obviously you got trey white who's
still one of the best corners of the
national football league i just feel
like he needs time to develop and i
think in that system dell schooling i
feel like he's a little bit loose in his
own coverage i'm not really a fan of
that i feel like he guesses a little bit
his effort he depends on his speed a
little bit and his press coverage he
lets guys get get the edge a little more
but i think those things can be
corrected and with good coaching and
they have good coaching in buffalo i
think he will develop into a better
player than if he would have went
somewhere else this is one of those
times where the scheme and the fit of
the team is actually going to benefit
the player tremendously similar to what
you hit here and see with the baltimore
ravens sure so you're kind of seeing
like sean mcdermott leslie frazier we're
expecting some time but those dudes can
expediate this process because they got
to slow down jamar chase they got to
slow down tyreek hill you see them
helping this prospect
no question i i see them seeing he has
the speed he has the size he has the
willingness to tackle and they're going
to tighten the boats they're going to
they're going
educate him they're gonna put him with
trey white they're gonna get his
footwork together his press get his
technique get him in lead position get
his 45 degree angles in his press make
sure that he understands his reads and
the routes to expect in zone coverage
and he's going to be a much better
player just because he's anticipating
things instead of reacting to everything
awesome richard sherman thank you so
much for the insight that's great you
know what sometimes you can take more
risks on guys that have so much athletic
potential when you know that you're an
organization that can handle that uh
dallas cowboys are up i'm looking at
jerry jones in his
darth vader-like room where he's looking
at his sons and he's treating one better
than the other just so that the other
one is more motivated to outwork the
other we're sitting here at 24. they
needed an edge rusher jermaine johnson
is still there they don't need
linebacker talent even though there's
some good ones that are out there but
i'm also looking at tyler linderbaum
and i'm kind of thinking this is a
dallas cowboys team that has been
wanting to invest in offensive line
because that's what they loved for all
these years what are you thinking here
they invest more assets into the
offensive line premium assets than any
team in football traditionally um so
when you look at it for dallas that
would not shock anyone as much as i'm i
don't i'm not convinced he's definitely
going in the first round for the talent
that he possesses right you know
jermaine johnson makes a ton of sense
but you you always have to wonder guys
what fires jerry up right that's what it
comes down to super athletes super so i
thought of like devin lloyd but they
already have micah parsons they have a
lot of linebackers louisian the safety
from georgia yeah freak show right so i
look at that one and think man
if they want somebody that really fires
you up with he's a thumper i mean he he
almost decapitated kyle pitts you're
talking about somebody that is just
ruthless coming downhill i was going to
say what if they go back to that penn
state well and i was looking at jaquan
british yes right and play yeah
that's the perspective out of penn state
uh let's get our let's get our gambles
what are we thinking i'll take brisker
i'm gonna go linder bomb
i'll go seen
okay all right and but i will say why do
we think jermaine johnson is still on
the board it's a great question you're
looking at a late breakout player now i
love the players so this is just me
trying to speak for what people could be
concerned about a 23 year old they had a
long road which i don't i don't
i don't know why that's an insult i
think it's impressive
that he didn't quit he didn't quit
and he's very self-aware he speaks about
it all the time juco georgia
developed a lot of georgia yes and then
said you know what i want to play more
yeah and he was right he went to florida
state and had 14 and a half sacks i mean
he is 23. so you think maybe his age is
something that's holding him back but he
tested he phenomenal tester yeah and
he's pro ready as violent hands he has
an array of passer when he gets picked
they'll go through the pass rush
movement yes
this just feels a little bit of
overthinking to me right now and you
know what good for somebody that'll get
germaine he might go to a contender now
which could be electric but it is a fall
it's his fault it's surprising to me all
right so the cowboys are still on the
clock um
in terms of reaches
more of a reach quay walker at 22
or penning at nineteen to the same place
walk her by a full round i mean what are
we what are we doing you know what we're
doing it's the green bay packers they do
this every year and where has it gotten
them recently where is is crying right
now yeah i'm sure no he's he's probably
cursing at somebody he's not a crier
he's a fu
so
i don't know i just i don't i don't get
it and green bay do you think there's
any chance that the cowboys would have
been looking at kair elam to necessitate
the bills jumping ahead of the cowboys
to take him there's a chance and i think
it goes back to this the bills paid the
hundred and thirtieth pick
they're a great team they're a great
role yeah they don't they're they're not
goals they're gonna camp with ten
rookies and they're gonna have to cut
someone you throw that pick away like
changing your pocket at the arcade it
doesn't matter no i just i'm
i don't know man i this with respect to
the cowboys i i think about it because
we mentioned we showed the team means we
had safety on there is there a
possibility that they were thinking that
elam could turn into that uh
there's a chance yeah there's absolutely
he has to see six one almost 200 pounds
they could be
thinking yeah say what safety blood
safety bloodlines they could be thinking
oh we could turn this guy into that and
the bills are like no we're gonna go get
em just because i know there's a lot of
teams at this part of the draft green
bay is coming up at 28 kansas city is
down there at 30. the cowboys are a team
that need a wide receiver too
who is the next wide receiver i have the
pick here and i'm not i'm not shocked by
this it is an offensive lineman i'm here
not a linderbox no i'm hearing it's
tyler smith the offensive tackle from
tulsa
uh who i liked a lot more than trevor
penning because of the upside 20 years
old tonight wow very young his birthday
no no he's 20 he's 24
all right so you're healing tyler smith
does the internet say michael silver
agrees tyler smith to the cowboys the
dallas cowboys they love drafted
offensive lineman and they love draft
and offensive lineman that are big 23
starts all left tackles did have a lot
of penalties
but 6'5 324 had 12 holding calls in 2021
because when you lose connor williams
somebody has to get penalized all the
time just kidding cowboys fans uh where
did you have him on your big board and
does 23 fit yeah it does 36 but it's
offensive line yeah you got a little bit
of a curve you got to pay the price to
get these offensive linemen and this is
an upside pick with tyler smith from a
franchise that invests in offensive line
as much as anybody in the nfl and he
usually works out pretty well for them
so i look at tyler smith i compared him
to taylor moton uh somebody with
the redirection the hands that he
doesn't even really know how to use his
hands yet they're all over the place and
he's still moving people down the field
that's what's so impressive to me if he
can clean up the hand technique start to
consistently get leveraged you see right
there they go off the screen gone
vanished wiped out i love that about
tyler smith he's a bully in the run game
he's a late uh a late developer
offensive line where he didn't start
playing offensive line until very late
in his high school career just the last
five years yeah very recent so there's a
lot of meat on the bone here i like to
say i think he can come in and play
guard right away yes the penalties are a
little bit of an issue but i think it's
he's just learning how to play tackle on
the fly at a school that let's be real
how many times they churn out first
round tackles right over and over again
so right i like the upside i really like
the idea of reinvesting an offensive
line that's gotten old and gotten hurt
over the years this was the right pick
they didn't panic they waited he fell
into their lap and he's a bully that
fits their identity so it's a b-plus for
me for tyler smith he's got a little bit
of developing to do but i think he'll do
it at guard right out of the gate wow
that was see that was i give it a b i'm
gonna i'm gonna was supposed to wait for
my pick i already went for the yeah
i went for the b plus as well because i
want to get to kelsey cause i want to
hear from him i i was gonna ask the
question i was gonna ask he kind of
tagged it on the back end
okay let's let's get it jason kelsey
i want to ask him
does this guy does he play tackle at all
in the nfl or is he someone that you
kick down the guard uh to start and then
he stays there full time
i mean he can definitely kick down the
guard he's got the size he's got the
metrics um he's a big big athlete raw
player um
you know i think he could definitely
play guard for sure um and that might be
the best place for him to start and then
all of a sudden blossom out to tackle uh
he's a bully in the run game would you
want in a guard he's physical his hands
are strong once they're on you you ain't
getting off so a lot of his traits
really do uh
fit well for a guard
another thing i wanted to get how do you
solve the how do you solve the penalty
issue the grabbing and we've talked
about that with a couple other guys how
do you solve the penalty issue what do
you do from a coaching standpoint what
would be your first steps
yeah a lot of holding comes down to body
position i mean i i led the league in
penalties dang near i led league in
holding calls one year and
you can definitely fix that that can be
coached out that can be taught
a lot of it's just learning uh when to
let go
where to put your body so it doesn't
happen like right there that's a big
grab like that you bring your hands up
in tight you're not gonna really get the
holding goal so there's definitely ways
to improve that um and he's so raw
that and young i mean the youngest
offensive lineman in the draft i think i
mean yep the fact that he's got so much
room to grow uh i'm sure that the the
cowboys are loving uh the potential down
the road for this kid either guard or
tackle jason kelsey thank you so much
yeah right now they've been able to play
taran steele at right tackle 27 starts
the last two years but also think about
this you can put him next to tyron smith
right now tyron smith is in his 12th
season tyron smith has been missing
games every year due to injuries so yeah
you can replace connor williams and
maybe slide this guy in at left guard
right now but it could be the future
investment in your left tackle if
you get him in there right coaching
staff could be a future investment as
well for the dallas cowboys the ravens
are on the clock we will get to that in
a second but first a message from rocket
mortgage
this crazy suit can give me an edge oh
yeah huge edge
invisibility gives aaron donald an edge
on his game who hit me just like a
verified approval gives you an edge on
your offer i did when you need a
competitive edge in the housing game
rocket cam
all right here are the big board two of
connor's top six players still available
to the top linebackers available we were
a little shocked way walker when i had a
devin lloyd and the kobe dean uh david
ajabo good pass rusher still up there so
two edge rushers a little surprising a
bunch of safeties the monster at a yukon
travis jones is there uh and then
a few more edge guys but what we're not
seeing is tackles and wide receivers
feel like those wells have run dry
yeah the only guy we got left uh who's
no i'm not as high on but he's he's a
good tackle prospect would be bernard
raymond a little bit of an older player
he could he could go on this tackle run
but man this is crazy right now right
take a look at these last 10 picks
felder what jumps out to you
i think for me it's aj brown being
traded
but what about you no the quick run on
those guards right green to berks to
obviously pinning yeah we expect to play
inside at least early uh if possible or
and then we obviously got tyler smith in
that mix as well and obviously the
biggest standout is still quite walker
that's the one that was the biggest
surprise yeah kitty pickett instead of
malik willis that kind of no doubt it
was a late shift in terms of
conventional wisdom
i'm this is i'm also loving the more i
think about the trent mcduffie pick the
more i'm falling in love with it yeah
the way that you guys talk about this
free range the fact that conor is
talking about his intelligence like that
yes that's the part of honey badger's
game that never gets enough credit is
how smart he is on the back end to run
that spagnolo defense and if you could
find that next version of him for a team
that's ready to go for a super bowl it
doesn't sound like he's gonna need too
much time ravens now were up
they blew you away with their first pick
at 14 with kyle hamilton it was a fun
one we're now sitting there they still
need a pass rusher when they were
sitting there at 14 we talked about
jermaine johnson possibly being the pick
if they leave this draft with kyle
hamilton and jermaine johnson it covers
up for the fact that they traded
hollywood brown a little bit oh yeah
they're trying to be the 2000 ravens
right and just kill everybody on defense
yeah i think when you look at i still
do have some questions offensively but
they've been all over jermaine johnson
throughout this process where i'd be a
little surprised if they let him buy
again what about the ravens going linder
bomb here
maybe i got one for you go for it
travis jones oh yeah we talked so much
about the ravens taking jordan davis
you're right
why not joe the other huge nostalgia
exactly the other humongous guy so that
was one that i've been looking going
through and i was like we haven't talked
about travis jones at all
uconn defensive tackle big boy could he
be the guy that ends up being the pick
yeah he reminds me of marcel darius that
kind of freaks six four 325 rana the
fact that all of the big defensive
lineman ran sub 540s yeah terrifying i
mean it just shows you the type of
athlete that exists right now so that's
your pick yeah and are you going to are
you going to echo that or you can also
jermaine and i know i just keep saying
it and he keeps falling so
joke's on me but uh that's what i think
they'll go with is there i'll try to
find out for us
there's no chance they go linebackers
here but if they were to draft a dev
employed i got it were any of us right
uh did you say linder bomb i did it is
linder bomb yo
yo boy your boy your boy's feeling good
i mean we know what this one is because
right now i looked at their offensive
line and their starting center is
tristan colon castillo and no offense to
tcc i've never heard of them before tcc
tcc was
like uh i don't know they got him in
2020. it doesn't make sense but you have
kevin zeitler to the right you drafted
tyre phillips two years ago you're
hoping uh
that ronnie stanley comes back and so
you go hey lamar jackson i know that we
just got rid of your favorite wide
receiver but now we're giving you a
center to protect you and now the
interior running lanes that they're
going to be able to open in that greg
roman defense should be pretty darn
interesting 62 296 is a two-time
first-team all-american the remington
award winner 35 consecutive starts at
center if you needed a center
this is the guy what do you think at 25
this i feel like was the range for him
dynamite i mean for me obviously top
five player in this draft ohio scouting
report one of the best college football
players in the entire nation a
fascinating debate over positional value
versus blue chip talent because if you
don't value centers
i mean i don't know what you're thinking
it does matter a lot and he is a blue
chip talent you're talking about a
dynamic athlete with an insane
background wrestling shot put discus
baseball team captain thank you for
writing that down because i saw that he
was a six sport athletes and i was like
there's six sports there's no sport yet
yeah he's probably playing water polo
and golf i mean there's nothing this guy
can't do got that iowa haircut his range
is unbelievable as a reach blocker he is
so lightning quick to the second level
of the field he's the best reach blocker
i think i've evaluated probably since
doing the draft yes and he loves playing
through the whistle he likes to really
just take the life out of you where i
watch the coaches tape and you watch the
overhead and you see guys complaining to
the refs about him after the play and
the ref looks at him like it's football
man tough luck tyler linderbaum is a the
tone setter gets thrown around in
football way too much he is the
definition of tone setter in the run
game wow i think his anchor's fine and
he doesn't have length but at center he
can get by with that comparison to our
friend on the show and this is this is
top flight praise and this praise
happened before we even decide booked
him for the show jason kelsey jason
kelsey so tyler linderbaum is an a-plus
pick
i think he'll be an all-pro player in
this league i really do yeah i mean i
echo all those symptoms this guy's a
bulldog right he gets under once he once
he gets on no pitbull once he locks on
you it's game over he's gonna move you
around and you might people are going to
look at him and say he's a little bit
small but once he gets those once he
puts the paws on you yeah he's going to
move you around he's going to put you in
the dirt you're going to be in trouble
so i'm going to go a plus as well uh
jason kelsey head coach kirk ferentz of
iowa said quote i don't know if it gets
any better
than tyler uh
our own connor rogers compared him to
you
what do you think
i think he's addre i i mean it's a great
comparison i think he's an unbelievable
player um obviously a little bit under
size which is why he's fallen like this
a little bit uh or i got it i have the
character undervalued um
but this dude is so polished all around
he's probably the best zone blocker
you're to see unbelievable reach blocker
unbelievable finisher
team captain who played multiple sports
i mean everything you want to see in an
offensive alignment this guy has so i
mean i'm a little surprised with the
baltimore just because they're not a
huge zone team they do a lot of power
schemes and gap schemes with that run
but um obviously they didn't care either
and i don't see the anchor issues i
really don't i see him sit down well i
think that wrestling background serves
him well he moves his feet really
quickly he's got good agilities this kid
is going to be a really really good
center i'm very confident that and
that's coming from the source jason
kelsey thank you so much so the jets
have now traded up to 26. who did they
trade with uh 26 should have been well
it was the titans but they the eagles no
either way i know who they they traded
to take jermaine johnson i got the trade
i think i got to break it first which is
did you just tweet that hey look who
that is that's you yeah i've been told
they traded back in to take jermaine
johnson um
obviously a player they were going to
take at 10 but they weren't able to
trade for a wide receiver and you know
obviously they're pretty
they're pretty jacked up about this are
you yeah
you broke the news and it's a guy that
we're like why is he falling talk about
you
i don't i don't like talking about
talking
about you i mean honestly this is an
exciting player because he's a top 10
player in the strap that a position need
all right so here it is i grew up in a
household with a jet season ticket
holder okay from new york my entire life
we do not know what a pass rusher looks
like oh i mean the only one i can
remember as a kid watching is john
abraham yes and
and that's it and it's been a long time
i mean i was like
watching and now i do this for a living
full-time right so uh shout out to my
dad at home who raised me a jets fan and
is he texted me when they're on the
clock at 10 and said this has to be
jermaine johnson and i said sorry dad
and now they go back into the draft and
obviously get him at 20 from everything
i've heard so where was he on your big
board jermaine johnson was now i'm
probably the highest on him in draft
media but he was my sixth overall player
and so why are you high on him what are
you seeing that other people aren't
seeing i i mean the best okay i know
other people that were high on him too
you're not crazy here the the best hands
i think of any pass rusher in the draft
besides maybe hutch um and it's close
it's close yes so
the get off the 10 yard split is an
elite metric for him and in robert
solo's defense you have to pin your ears
back get up field and get after the
quarterback that's what they ask you to
do now you get away from that right
great hands to set a hard edge against
the run which is something felder and i
talked about on the phone eight million
times yeah he sets a hard edge against
the run he's the guy that i'm watching
tape of ikea kwanu and i said who the
hell just pulled that spin move that
left ikea kwanu looking like somebody
just pulled a houdini disappeared it was
jermaine johnson spin move push pull rip
dip
violent hands can turn the corner good
it's good enough he can flatten into the
pocket
i'm not saying he's going to be miles
garrett or chase young that's what i'm
saying but he's a he's a captivating
player from juco to georgia to florida
state where he went to florida state and
said i wanted i wanted to play more and
you hear him at the combine and a lot of
guys get defensive when you ask them why
did it take you so long to break out and
he's not like that he's very self-aware
uh he's he's a great fit for a locker
room he's very likable person he's very
hard worker he reminds me of matt judon
who just never stops going it's go go go
go go the jets needs a pass rush for
robert solid they would have taken him
at 10 if they solved the wide receiver
problem in the offseason they failed at
that so they took garrett wilson and
they still get jermaine johnson into the
first round this is an a-plus
i think he's finally gonna end the john
abraham curse we'll see wow so jermaine
johnson this is what i love you talk
about this long journey he ends up at
florida state and he's the team captain
and the teammates when they were asked
about him said
he is a first one in last one out we all
love him uh what do you think of this
guy and the fact that he fell to them at
26. i mean that i i think he's an a
player in general i do a lot of acc work
so i've seen plenty of this guy totally
over the course of the year and the big
thing that i really loved about him was
his versatility because conor mentioned
all of the moves but let's look at where
he's lined up right here right lined up
right off the outside of that offensive
lineman okay he can make a tackle
running laterally let's see where he's
lined up on this next play okay he's
lined up inside of that wing i can do
this i can go make a play i loved his
ability to line up different places i
love the fact that he's a fighter his
effort never lacked that's another part
that people don't talk about you see
there are the patience to watch the
quarterback give and then close down to
make the tackle a lot of guys closed
down immediately that quarterback's out
the gate 88 so i love that part of his
game the big thing for me that i'm going
to be looking for watching him is how he
gets used do you want him just coming
off the ball or is he a guy that you're
going to play more downs so that he can
set the edge and he can be a defender in
the run game i think he can do all those
things i'm going to give it an a i love
this pick i think it's great that he's
got value for them at that point and the
big thing for me again with him is you
can line him up a bunch of different we
saw him line up standing up yep hand
down yep inside of a wing outside of a
tight end heads up on a tight end
outside of a tackle head up on a tackle
inside of a tackle he can do a bunch of
different felder tell him i mean i just
i i appreciate a guy that's willing to
do all those things because there's a
lot of guys that just say i'm a
defensive end i line up wide yes and
he's someone that said i'll do what it
takes to help my team win uh this is a
team that was 26 in the nfl in sex
and the jets now leave this first round
with sauce gardner
garrett wilson and jermaine johnson and
with that excitement i can only imagine
what the jets room is like on the br app
so let's put connor rogers inside the
jets room let's see some of these
comments
has actually been faster than me what an
effing draft wow outstanding
uh 35 and what trey jd is a genius man
uh
has actual pass rush moves
uh
man
how are you feeling it's awesome and you
know honestly like not to be selfish for
a moment but no better knows how much i
love this player to break that news for
me was the coolest moment i've had in a
draft
and and thank you to the person that
that allowed me to i think they knew
like you're you're in love with this
player and this is the team that you've
like i will have to post the picture
tomorrow like i'm like a little kid
watching this stupid team on tv it's
it's a cool moment it really is yeah i'm
so happy yeah man good night for us
we're both look at us look at us
who would have thought uh so the jaguars
just traded up with the bucks which
makes sense because a lot of the guys
the bucks would have wanted are no
longer their
team needs
so the jaguars are moving up from 33 so
who could they want that they had to
move up back into the end of the first
round to get what are we thinking
man
details from my guy jordan schultz uh
jaguars got 27 and the the uh the bucks
are gonna pick up it looks like a late
third fourth uh here could it be for
lewis seen how are they are they trying
to get more dynamic athletes on the back
end i was going to say could it be for
raymond and ryan
i'm going to say
that i think
it could be uh the linebacker because
levante david is 32 and a free agent
after this year and i'm looking at devin
lloyd and now i'm thinking if you
partner up devin lloyd and devon white
that we're on jacksonville we're on
jacksonville the jags traded up damn
i was thinking about tampa bay i got so
excited okay so the jaguars
who would who did you guys just say i
brain farted i said uh i said bernard
raymond
offensive tackle because they went
walker with the first pick to get dn so
and we complained about them not
protecting trevor lawrence but here's
the problem felder and this is you're
right this is a gm that took uh walker
little last year in the second round is
he going to be defensive of i think i'm
right about my guy i was right and i
didn't even talk about the right team
is that the jaguars devin lloyd he said
mars lost miles jack in the off-season
and said we need an athlete that can
roam and devin lloyd is that guy
6-3 247 out of utah consensus
all-american team captain
i mean he had 43 tackles for loss 16 and
a half sacks five interceptions you won
it he got it and he goes to jacksonville
at 27. they traded up to get him what do
you think of the value there freaking
awesome i mean
13th overall player for a team that i've
had some questions about their free
agency period i've had some questions
about obviously the top of this draft
this is a ball player right this is a
three down player felder and i did a
little exercise where we went through
all the aspects of him in the kobe
dean's game and what i like about lloyd
is he can run sideline a sideline you
see him zone drop right there and read
the ball and take it back to the house
for six he's the kind of guy that
doesn't think i'm out here to make
tackles and make plays and get off the
field i'm the kind of guy that i make
big time plays game-changing plays
i want everything i'm going to live in
the backfield and then the craziest
thing left go this will blow your mind
you watch him with his hand in the dura
as a pure pass rusher on third downs
where they say don't worry about the run
hand in the dirt defensive end the get
off the hands the spin move he's quietly
one of the best pass rushers in this
draft quietly he can do everything he's
not just an off-ball linebacker people
need to stop saying that about him
jacksonville got a little bit of pass
rush help here a big-time middle of the
defense force i love devin lloyd a plus
for jacksonville this is the kind of
players they need more of well home that
home runs but triples doubles you guys
weren't that high on travon walker but
now i'm thinking about him and lloyd and
we were thinking about what kelsey was
saying about the multiplicity and how
you could use these guys but focus on
lloyd here i feel like you love this guy
i really do i think he's the second best
linebacker in the draft and
but that doesn't mean i don't like him
and we did that thought exercise of dean
vs lloyd and it's kind of in anything
you can do i can do better and his
ability as an off the ball linebacker
this guy's a tracker that's what i've
got in kind of he's he's a guy he's
going to hunt you down he's going to get
you down on the ground he's going to
find you he's he doesn't get caught up
in the trash which i think is awesome
you see him there
collision disengage make a tackle in the
hole that's what a linebacker is
supposed to do here we go slow slow slow
here i come get you down on the ground
yes i like that he understands the ohio
state speed he's facing right here yes
it is and look at him running it down
shooting that gap not anybody he knows
that i'm fast enough to make the play so
for me i'm not going to give him i'm not
going to go plus
because i still think dean's better
but i'm going to go a
b
because lloyd's a really good player and
i do love again kelsey mentioned it
connor mentioned it but the ability to
take this guy on third and 12 and kick
walker down the rush from a three to let
this guy come from that five or from a
seven that gives you a lot of scheme
versatility also is going to cause
problems for uh for offenses
uh it is gonna be devin lloyd who utah
head coach kyle whittenham says watches
as much film during the course of a week
as anybody we've ever had ever
now you think about the weapons that
they have in that front seven caleb on
chaisson they have josh allen they have
trevon walker they have devin lloyd they
have they now have little pieces from
mike caldwell's defense where
i still think we're sitting here going
when are you going to help out your
first pick in the draft trevor lawrence
when is that going to happen they do
have though a league high 12 picks they
probably lost one in this trade to come
up and get them but a winner that you
guys have liked on every level level and
i'll say this left go i think they
feel like they spent a lot of money on
offense in free agency i see what you're
saying that they wanted to leave the
christian kirk say jones have an ingram
brand yeah sure sheriff they wanted to
open the door to take the best
robinson yes whether people agree with
that or not it's it's the
these are the players they think are the
best available and i respect that so now
we're sitting here and the team that
shocked our faces
is back on drafting quay walker earlier
on the packers are sitting here
and i'm just going
there's no way they're going to draft
another defensive player is there
there's no way that they trade devonte
adams and don't take another offensive
player
could we get a a wide receiver in a sky
moor could we get a wide receiver in
pickens could we get a wide receiver in
uh christian uh out of uh north dakota
state
what are we thinking here
christian watson it's green bay so put
on they're not gonna do george jordan
let's just do something stupid thank you
so let's just do something that makes no
sense okay let's try um
i'm going to say matt ariza punched it
punch no stop
all right i'm done being a jerk the one
that would make no sense would be malik
willis the one that would make a lot of
no sense would be nakobi dean and
they're like we accidentally drafted the
wrong georgia linebacker so we're going
to draft the right georgia linebacker
that would be remarkable so i'll say
this i think
they would consider devante wyatt d-line
from georgia travis jones felder brought
up before what's their tight end
situation like
uh they are waiting for uh the dude to
recover from uh uh leg injury
don't show it oh you're showing it
devonte wyatt there you go there we go i
mean aaron rodgers must be losing his
mind right now yeah of course
after trading devonta adams we all
thought well the packers are gonna find
themselves a wide receiver with two
picks in the 20s but no they fell in
love with two defensive players from
georgia you can't blame them george's
defense was incredible this year first
they go quay walker now they're going
devonta wyatt out of georgia 6-6 341
an absolute mauler down there on the
d-line where did you expect this guy to
go right around here is where it would
start okay uh somebody that tested
really well a late breakout i know i
keep running that into the ground but i
want to add context why such a good
player makes it this far
around 24 year old rookie season now you
see him right there play shade knows he
can play three tech you can kick him all
over the offensive line he's got really
good burst uh reminded me of darron
payne a first round player from a couple
years ago that's a lot of praise so
devonte white a really good player he's
ready to go too there's no developing or
okay he's really well rounded he could
rush the passer he could shoot gaps he
could stop the run uh he can hold the
point of attack he plays very very hard
obviously down after down there's not a
georgia defender that did not give you
120 percent every single snap so for
divine i like devonte why at the player
is 34th overall player i did write this
as a need for the packers when doing 8
000 mock drafts who's always wide
receiver and then maybe devonta wyatt or
someone like that
their plan as a whole is what kind of
just has me wondering what is really
going on here for aaron rodgers but at
the end of the day when you like the
player it's a b plus because i think
devante wyatt is really good and he will
be really good on a very talented
defensive line this is a run defense
that was abysmal they were averaging 4.7
yards allowed per rush
60 of the time that you ran on the
packers last year on third down you
converted so they did need this guy and
i know that i was getting excited about
jordan davis earlier you like this guy
more than jordan yeah i think that he's
a little more versatile and unless he's
not the same big package the same you
know kind of like oh my goodness but
when i look at what he does he's a truly
a guy that it's not an experiment if he
can play from a zero to a four i this is
a guy that we've seen play from a zero
to a four i so this is listen for
everybody out there from missouri show
me show me the show me state he's
already shown you what he can do i love
this i'm gonna go with an a minus
only dropping the minus on because
like you connor i still don't understand
how you think this is going to be the
thing that gets you to the super bowl
right if you're not going to help aaron
rodgers yeah we got the car but we don't
know where we're going it's a problem
right now let's bring in our guy jason
kelsey i'm imagining this d-line for the
packers where it's kenny clark and
devonta wyatt surrounded by rashaan gary
and preston smith and that is a big
athletic group this kid devonte wyatt
kelsey what do you think
i i love him i think he's a guy that the
moment you put on the tape he flashes uh
he's got great suddenness great
quickness
uh but more than anything you can tell
he's smart he's savvy yeah he finds a
way to get through the gap he finds a
way to beat people whether it's in the
run or the pass um you know i i like the
jordan davis kid that we got but this
kid is there's something that's unique
about this guy i think the duron payne
uh
uh comp from uconn it was pretty good
too i mean
i really liked watching him play he was
one of the more fun guys i had watch him
play he just doesn't stop he's just
something about him that i mean look at
that he's fighting through that i mean
he's a really good player yeah he finds
a way it looks like to dip that shoulder
and really slash in there i'm just
curious jason before we let you go like
what do you think aaron rodgers is
thinking right now
well i mean he's probably not too happy
i mean i'm sure he would have loved to
get a receiver
i'm sure he would have loved for them to
trade some of these picks for aj brown
like my man howie roseman uh uh i think
uh you know
yeah but you know i mean at the end of
the day uh you know
i think the green bay knows that uh
rogers can uh can make something happen
with anything that's
uh unfortunate for aaron that uh he's so
good that you uh that the team probably
thinks that no matter what he's gonna go
out there and be able to perform but um
not our problem right jason look at us
look at us that's right
look at us
love you pal
oh man all right thank you jason kelsey
okay
uh
so i just want one thing to wrap it up
so what does devonta wyatt do that
jordan davis doesn't do that you like
devante wyatt more all the different
positions that he's already played so
jordan you kind of see jordan as this is
what he does and devante is what i know
he does right he might be able to do
some others because devante devonte and
rashaan gary
those two next to each other right man
those guys are dangerous those are two
guys coming out of college that have
played all over the place and then when
i think of the fact that in the back is
jair alexander and eric stokes
that's a heck of a defense yeah maybe
that's the way that that's how they want
to play so go for it aaron rodgers not
gonna be happy no cause aaron rodgers
right now has alan lazar randall cobb
and sammy watkins
it's tough yeah it's tough uh patriots
are on the clock shocked by this pick do
you have the pick yeah and and i will
say this before you show it don't show
it yet okay the patriots
always take a guy
that we're not expecting now i'll just
say this
the kobe dean is on the clock is
available yeah clearly that's not who it
is no the kid out of connecticut the big
deal brother you ain't getting this one
so uh let me just i just wanna i'm gonna
take a look at yours
geez
can i just get offense or defense
offense okay i mean it stinks because
it's once again i love this guy as a
youtube player it's always got to be a
team that ruined that the the one that
just popped up was uh greg dolcich no
it's it's not him it's not him you got
the right idea like that wasn't a bad
cade auton
no no it's not a tight end
cult
that's strange
wow okay so the new england patriots go
to tennessee
chattanooga for 6'5
307 cole
strange you want to hear something funny
though i want you to tell me all the
things so the player comp for me which
this always happens every year when you
start to really figure out teams was joe
tooney life right he's not joe tuney
that's not fair i don't do that to
players joe tooney light like you could
see the small school product the
movement uh the interior zone blocking
on the move
obviously a tough player when he played
tennessee and kentucky i was very
impressed against that level of
competition and against kentucky he
really moved people out of the way he's
a tough guy he's an elite athlete okay i
can't emphasize that enough with cole
strange when you look at it uh he's
somebody that can test it off the chart
it's about a 995 relative athletic score
that's elite that means he's one of the
best testing centers of all time and he
didn't just play center 42 snaps at left
guard
starts at left guard a left tackle
center first team all-american
team captain with a 3.71 gpa and he was
an academic all-conference but this is
where it gets crazy
all six years
how bonus year
this man is experienced and but the the
the versatility that's a quote the
multiplicity that is experienced so the
fact that he goes to the patriots though
it's immediately like oh he'll be great
yeah
he'll fit exactly what they want where
you don't kill the pick now he's my i
think 89th player and you're valuing
you know i i liked cam jurgens better
than him so i want to talk centers here
linderbaum's gone so you're not going to
kill them because they didn't pass on
tyler linderman right strange
older prospect once again elite
athleticism fits what they want to do
obviously joe tooney light we know how
much the whole joe toony story with them
obviously worked out he's 23 going on
24. yeah he's an older player uh i just
look at this and think that
man i think everybody thought he was
going in the third round where he's
going to be a good player so you don't
kill the pick right i can't emphasize
that enough but it's just
do you care about the draft board
i don't think
that's not
that's not good that's a problem so i
would imagine that he slides in at right
guard maybe next to james for rents or
instead of james writes but wait what
was your grade for this i'm excited to
hear it my grade for this is a c plus
because once again he's he's not a bad
player and he fits what they want to do
this is not the player you take in the
first round it's just the value doesn't
check out he's not going to make that
level of impact for you so i like that
they're investing in offensive line but
overall i just think this is a reach uh
felder they traded shaq mason to the
bucks they lost ted carris in free
agency so they did lose both starting
guards
how how much of a fan are you of cole
strange i like him and again you
mentioned the athleticism i think the
big key for me that he was dominant at
his level and he didn't have the
penalties we talked about other players
coming out of the fcs he doesn't have
the the the the the setting problems or
the grabbing problems that we've talked
about with players coming out of the g f
the group of five it's 12 years to
figure it out
listen let me tell you guys something
trying to track the these the co the
bonus covered your players it's not been
easy okay so give us a break here but
he's a good player for me i'm gonna go b
minus because i'm thinking we're not
worried about him getting a center
they're not worried about employing
center right now they're worried about
how he fits with them at guard exactly
and ultimately they may be they may they
may end up have
drafting a guy that grows into a big
time center for them in the next few
seasons
he is now the first tennessee
chattanooga player since terrell owens
to be drafted in the top five rounds mr
jason kelsey apparently you've watched
video of cole strange what do you think
about him joining bill belichick and the
patriots
yeah i mean this is like
such a patriots way pick i mean
this guy is
can play guard center
i mean
super old school type player almost like
he just finishes extra hard and there's
just like a nastiness and a grit to him
i love watching his tape he's a guy
that's been climbing as people watch
more of them
um and i think he's going to fit in so
well in new england uh i mean look at
this he's just a nasty dirty player and
i like i like his tape i really do
all right and if it's coming from you
then i believe it bill belichick
drafting the patriots way player cole
strange out of tennessee chattanooga we
are now up to kansas city i'm looking at
television
they're still on new england connor has
already cheated me and felder will play
a little guessing game they traded up
earlier and they got trent mcduffie and
you know what we were worried that the
patriots were going to steal the chiefs
pitch i have a feeling felder the chiefs
were not going to be going after cole
strange no no we're not so we're sitting
here the needs that i thought that they
needed were wide receiver they get the
corner back and they need an edge so the
question is is it an edge or is a wide
receiver who are you going with i'm
gonna go david ojabo um i like that pic
i am gonna go
okay so i think it could be ojabo i
think it could be carla loftus but i
don't think it's them but they've been
mocked a lot at taking christian watson
and so i'm gonna go christian watson
okay and you're going david ajabo
i was should have gone with george carl
office
is that who you had as well connor yeah
someone's just texting me obviously the
the pics as they roll into the facts
gotcha yeah so they are going george
carloftus and just like that the chiefs
answer both of their defensive needs
heading into this draft george carlofta
second-team all-american 14 and a half
sacks 30 and a half tackles for losses
his training his nutrition are insane
and his coach jeff brohm says
lives in the building
to get him here at 30 connor thoughts
good value adam is the 28th best player
in the draft i think he's a really high
floor player that gives you
you know obviously strong hands against
the run he knows how to read and react
obviously the effort is off the charts
the first step stands out to me uh i
think is he the most twitched up player
or short area quickness or super fast
supercharged closing speed to the
quarterback i don't think he's that i
think that's why you're looking at maybe
an eight-sack kind of player maybe his
peak years he hits 10 uh because of the
effort and once again he sets a hard
edge against the run he has a really
interesting background you know coming
from overseas where he grew up playing
water polo so he attributes the leg
strength to that and it's real the leg
straight he has a really good base to
contain against the run and for the
chiefs this is the kind of pass rusher
you're not going to swing for the fences
on a jabbo or boye mafe this is a little
bit more of a high floor player that
gives you a lot of upside against the
run and gives you that effort across
from frank clark and if you're playing
the bills he can withstand if you're
going to go run game
i like this pick it's it's a solid b
plus for me i think it obviously he's a
pro ready player um you see the
comparison to trey flowers there you
guys know what trey flowers can do
against the run so yeah that's the kind
of player he is yeah i for me i love i
love the pick i love carloftus i i think
he's a
he's we we we we gush so much we've
created this new position that's not
even really a position of edge right
yeah yeah it went from hybrid linebacker
and guys that play defensive ends and
now we just lump them all together
together as edge carl after this is a
defensive end he is a defensive end and
i like that about him i'm going to go
with an a minus i like the fact that
they drafted a true defensive end
someone's going to come in set the edge
hard and then squeeze down to get to the
quarterback he's not going to run around
you he's going to squeeze down to get to
the quarterback and i think that's
important because this is going to bring
some toughness to attend to a excuse me
a kansas city team that a lot of people
view because of their offense as a
finesse team absolutely and i want to
add to that
what kansas city tried to do last year
because they couldn't get a pass rush
was move chris jones defensive end but
what happened was is they became awful
against the run
now you get to play chris jones at his
natural position where he's a great pass
rusher interior and you get to partner
up frank clark and carloftus both guys
that can play the run and are nasty
against the pass now melvin ingram is
still a free agent they might bring them
back but now suddenly the chiefs have
depth on their d line and now they have
depth in their secondary two things that
were an issue for them so so far brett
veach attacking defense
uh
our draft coverage is brought to you by
rocket mortgage how do i know there's
words on the screen underneath the
camera that tell me so if you're looking
for an edge in the home buying market
don't call your cousin cheryl that has
connections you've got to go to rocket
mortgage cheryl barely can use facebook
their verified approval can help you
compete in a crowded market which you
don't want to be in during these times
and give you the edge you need an edge
that would rival george carloftus rocket
mortgage rocket can
ting
that was an ad read connor's big board
of who is left
we've got ojabo nakobi dean hard-hitting
uh safety louisian
but i feel like your favorite player is
dax hill he is
i look at dax hill and i just think
i wrote down this line that builders
probably tired of me saying over and
over again but it just it makes sense
he's a dream chess coverage piece for a
defensive coordinator where anything you
ask of him i mean truly with the
athleticism and size he could play
corner on the outside right he's just so
good
in the slot and at traditional sit-free
safety that that's where he's played and
he can roam single high too high we've
seen him do it we've seen him do all
those things we've seen him light up as
a nickel we've seen him line up as an
outside corner we've seen him line up as
a single high he can do all those things
we've seen him do it it's interesting
that we're talking about him did you get
the pick did you cheat no no no i don't
know it's done so the cincinnati bengals
are on the clock lost in the super bowl
to the la rams had a phenomenal year
they took uh
our guy jamar chase over penne sewell
this offseason went out there got lyle
collins got kappa got karis kind of
rebuilt that old line i still feel like
oh line is a need if you had to guess
for the bengals here who would you give
them so i thought the same as either
they can go one more offensive line but
the premium players are gone yes you
look at it they want to think somebody i
talked to close to cincinnati said they
want to think about the next three years
in the secondary not because jesse bates
is upset that he got the franchise tag
von bell's going to be a free agent as
well apple on a one year and they play a
lot of three safeties could it be lewis
seen here it could be seen it could be
dax hill it could be andrew booth you
could see them go corner corner
i think brisker's in the mix as well
because brisker has shown a ton of
versatility
not just not in the same way as dax hill
but he's shown a lot of versatility yep
all right let's hear your guesses
felder you're first
i mean
if you want versus don't show it ah crap
jackson hill yeah i mean a second it's
daxton hill so you love this vic oh it's
a this is a phenomenal pick phenomenal
man phenomenal i mean you once again who
are they running into lefko kansas city
cheese buffalo bills
you got to be able to line up the field
and run with these guys and make plays
on the football this is what he does
makes plays on the football slot two
high single high wherever you need him
here you go let's run it this is a blast
take it away left go the bat the
cincinnati bengals went out got a first
team all big ten safety in dax hill 23
starts 20 passes defended has led the
wolverines and passed defended at
interceptions last year was the number
one safety in his recruiting class
never missed a game in college and if
you remember justice hill the running
back taken by the ravens who was a spark
athlete off the charts this is his
younger brother and this is a bengals
team that loves to invest in safeties
you love this guy i love this guy first
off elite athlete right we're talking
about elite metrics a sub 4 4 speed 95th
percentile 10 yard split that initial
burst 97th percentile three cone 657
change of direction 97th percentile
elite athlete and he's not just let me
get on the track let me get on the field
and shorts he tackles he plays the ball
in the air he'll press guys he'll blitz
he'll read the quarterbacks he does
everything this is a dream coverage
piece for that secondary where he could
play in the slot he could play
traditional free safety i really think
he can play corner if you ask them to
and what everybody missed with this
michigan tape is aiden hutchinson and
david jabo they deserve all the praise
in the world when you watch the tv tape
those are the guys to get all the action
when you watch the coaches tape who's
the guy on the back end that's making
life hell for the opposition it's
jackson hill i he's my 23rd overall
player in this draft i thought he should
have went way earlier than this he
reminds me of malcolm jenkins once again
i'm not throwing out these home run
comps these crazy comps this was one
where i feel comfortable it's a huge
expectation comp but he's worth it he's
an a plus pick for me for a team that
you know even i had my times like how
are they going to get back there next
year what they've done in free agency
and now in the first round phenomenal
for the bengals yeah i want to get to
sherman because i want to hear his
thoughts on him but i love the swiss
army knife capabilities that's what i've
got dax in hell labeled as swiss army
knife a guy that we've seen when they go
when when michigan went to that bare
front they played cover zero guess what
daxton hill's the guy that they put as
an outside corner when they went into
that their traditional nickel mode they
put him over the slot this is a guy that
can play off man he can play in that
zone
interception against wisconsin that's
him playing in the nickel sliding out
the sink up underneath in coverage he's
played cloud corner he's played that
hook to curl as a nickel he's played a
single high safety he's played two high
safeties he's a guy that can get off the
hash and cover too as well as he can
play in the middle of the field and then
beat you to the sideline with that elite
athleticism that connor mentioned i'm
going a plus wow
i mean i just think he's he's amazing
watching him play is just it's a treat
when you pop in his tape all right
richard sherman now they have jesse
bates von bell and dax hill thoughts on
the player and the fit with cincinnati
i think it's a great fit i think in the
super bowl last year you saw their say
their secondary played well but at the
corner spot uh eli apple struggled and
they didn't have an answer for it they
didn't have anybody that could go in
there and change the dynamic i think
they got a player now who can be
versatile enough to be inside to be
outside to be at the safety spot it
makes jessie bates and von bells
a lot more interchangeable in terms of
who's going to be in the box who's going
to be in the middle field who's blitzing
i think it just gives them a lot of
flexibility and that's what they need
you know i mean if he has to go to
corner
just to get him on the field i think
that's awesome i think they're happy to
do that i think he his versatility is
going to make him really cool and a
really important piece of that defense
early on and maybe if jesse bates can't
get a deal next year
they move him back to safety but i think
i mean he changes a lot for the
cincinnati defense richard sherman thank
you so much the pick dax hill for the
cincinnati bengals checking in on our
little social media board just kind of
going over the picks cole strange at 29
dax hill uh
man some interesting names here but just
like this we are down to the vikings at
32 because they traded back earlier uh
and i i'm looking at the names that are
still on the board and the one that's
sticking out to me is malik willis and
every mock that i heard there was some
team that was trading up to pick 32 to
lock in a quarterback to that fifth year
option so we could be waiting for a
trade i'm sure that and you know what
what's interesting it's a brand new gm
in minnesota yeah you're gonna learn a
lot and i i'm always curious with what
kind of connections does a new gm have
to make these calls uh kawesi adofu
mensah but apparently the pick is in
don't reveal it
don't reveal it
who do we think they're going with
minnesota vikings they didn't make a
pick they had 12. they i forgot they
traded with their inner division rival
the lions so the lions can move up to
jamison wilson williams who do we think
the vikings do here a lot of turnover at
corner they needed a big defensive
lineman
i'm going to go with travis jones out of
connecticut that's who i'm going to
guess that they're taking yeah that's a
good one i'm going to let me let me just
double check let me double check
i look at two of my best players
available right now david ojabo who you
have to draft and staff she's coming off
the ruptured achilles right but you have
the infrastructure where you could
survive with that danielle hunter we
don't know how much longer he's going to
be there he brought zadaria smith in
right you have two edge pass rushers
that you can wait on him i'd like that
pick and then i just i go to the talent
here i look at louisiana still on the
board i've heard for weeks he's not
making out of the first round i'd be
really surprised if he does but now
we're in crunch time here for lunch i
like scene i was thinking him i'm gonna
go the other position in the second room
i'm gonna go corner i'm gonna go andrew
booth
i'm gonna go andrew booth
that's interesting zimmer's not there
that would have been a zimmer picture
all right let's see the minnesota
vikings by the way they're just doing
the bengals pick on tv
we don't do that because they slow and
this is the internet we do what we want
so let's see the pick is lewis seen
there we go
good for him jordan schultz breaking it
they did have a hole there
right next to harrison smith and they
fill that immediately with a safety that
if you haven't seen him will blow your
top off second team all sec kirby smart
said when you design a safety he's got
all the qualities and he is a student of
the game lewis seen six to about 200
will now be back there with harrison
smith for the minnesota vikings
i imagine the value is pretty strong
here yeah the value is obviously
tremendous when you look at scene 21st
on the board right a dynamic athlete
just the not the way he tested but the
way he plays four three seven speed that
133 broad is an elite metric and you see
it on tape he's explosive he's the train
coming down the tracks that can make the
hit but felder you and i have watched
this play a lot of times it goes to show
you yes what's going on up top in the
brain bingo i think because of the
highlight reel tackles people have
missed how intelligent he is he was the
guy on the back end of the georgia
defense getting everybody lined up
making plays reliable on coverage on the
plays you don't see the throws that
didn't come his way he does have ball
skills but really the name of his game
is the
the hit stick coming downhill in the
alley that he's terrifying he's
terrifying he you don't want to see him
coming downhill at you if you're running
the seam uh you better be you better
hold on to that ball for dear life
because he will pop you he took off kyle
pitz's head so lewis seen a first round
player for me a top 25 player for me the
kind of athlete that you bet on in the
first round the kind of tape you bet on
in the first round i like it from
minnesota this is somebody that should
have won earlier this is an a for me
from minnesota and we're going to learn
you know obviously a new regime there
this is a really really good start this
is a not a foundation player because i
don't know if you say that about every
single pick but somebody that is going
to be there for a long time
i love scene all right this dude he's i
mean he's a soul crusher he will come
down and make you pay i love the hit
against michigan where
running back has an alley and then all
of a sudden he doesn't have an alley
anymore and he does not want to get up
off the ground because seen just
destroys he's a he's a heat-seeking
missile that just wants to come down and
really wreak havoc on people he is
good in past coverage and i love the
play that we showed against tennessee
where he helps nicoby dean has beat on
that play and seems like don't worry i
will erase this mistake for you but i
also love watching scene in game point
things out
call things out
show things that need to go over and get
guys in the right position he was a
leader on the field and i think we got
to mention the intelligence i think
that's so important when we talk about
these guys he's clearly a student of the
game i'm going a plus there it is
because you're getting someone who is
truly capable of making plays in every
facet of the game and you're getting
them at the end of the first round when
players that are not as good as him
right i have already gone off the board
all right minnesota vikings taking lewis
scene richard sherman you've played with
some great safeties in your career what
do you think when you watch lewis scene
out of georgia
i love it i love it he was a former
defensive player of the year in high
school obviously he was the mvp of the
national championship minnesota had the
28th ranked pass defense last year and
that's not really how that defense works
usually they're amongst the top 10.
harrison smith has been in that system
for a long time i expect louisiana to
come in and make an immediate impact and
fit right in they're disciplined they
run that quarter system um ed donatello
has just been hired as the coordinator
so i expect that to continue
and i think he's going to be a plug and
play fit for them i think he's really
smart he's instinctual he's fast he
plays fast he plays aggressive he may
need to put on a few pounds just to to
be able to to
deal with the the rough
rugged nfl lineup the running backs and
the things that he's going to have to
deal with week in and week out but i
think it's going to be a great fit
all right richard sherman breaking it
down lewis seen the safety out of
georgia going to minnesota it is pretty
wild that we have had five georgia
players get drafted and the kobe dean is
not one of them but that's how it goes
sometime before we wrap up we have a
message from rocket mortgage correct
so why don't we listen to the people at
rocket mortgage and then we're gonna
break down our favorite picks our big
winners from round one but first this
this crazy suit gonna give me an edge oh
yeah huge edge
invisibility gives aaron donald an edge
on his game who hit me just like a
verified approval gives you an edge on
your offer i did when you need a
competitive edge in a housing game
rocket cam
all right two tweets first one from
lamar jackson uh i think that means we
the force no it doesn't it means what
the f
that is the trade of hollywood brown
wish i could have played with my brother
forever but i'ma see you at the top and
like like you said he realized man i got
to play
well i get to play with kyler murray i
know him really well
uh but man uh
very very interesting um
what happened there so we were wondering
were we going to see some wide receiver
trades uh is debo samuel going to get
moved we did see two impending free
agents uh following year get traded one
in hollywood brown one in debo samuel
we had
overall a lot of trades happen we saw an
early run on wide receivers where i
think six of them went in the top 18. um
we only saw one quarterback drafted in
kenny pickett malik willis not drafted
and i think overall
we didn't really know what was going to
happen at any time in this draft uh
i think that there was a few reaches
quay walker stands out at 22 to the
green bay packers uh penning at 19 to
the saints but that was mainly because
of the offensive line run and we're
ready for that one yeah and i think with
needing to fill tyron armstead um but
let's do our big winners and so connor
would you like to lead us off are you
ready no i want to i want to kind of
dive in and digest everything that we
had here actually no i i we could talk
it out and we'll come up with our
winners i know i'm going to pick my
winner and i'm i'm not going to take the
jets just to make everybody well aware
of that i was going to give you the job
no i want you if you want the jets
they're yours uh i'll take the jets yeah
well then why don't you just do the jets
and then we'll have connor china yeah
i'll do the jets man are you kidding me
you look at the jets and you look at
what they're picking so obviously it
starts out because this is a roller
coaster right so we start out with the
jets and they they pick sauce gardener
feels good because you get the number
one corner and you get him after another
team took stingley but you're still like
we didn't really adjust the thing that
we wanted to address don't worry you're
gonna come down here at 10 and you're
gonna get wilson okay we got garrett
wilson so we did address that wide
receiver spot we were able to adjust the
wide receiver spot okay that feels good
and then where's where the gesture is oh
no we missed out on an edge rusher it's
not on the head dresser don't worry
coming down here pick 26
johnson we got him we were able to get
these guys on they got all the guy they
got basically they got all the guys they
wanted yeah yeah they got three possible
top 10 picks on people's boards yeah and
like the only thing the only thing that
would have been
even more was if they were able to get
one of those top three offensive linemen
somehow but they they addressed
everything they wanted they got help for
zach wilson they got help for that edge
rush and they got the best corner in the
draft
they're winners they are big winners
man it's it's hard to disagree i mean
you love the maneuverability right to
get back into round one for a player
they had as a top 10 player in this
draft a player they would have taken at
10.
but you know the deal when you're that
regime if zack wilson fails you fail so
you have to take garrett wilson who i
really love we love gary wells i think
he's the best receiver in the draft it's
awesome but there's a little part of you
that just goes man what about the edge
rush though and then to still walk away
with jermaine johnson that's really
really exciting for me
when i look at this draft just what the
eagles were able to do
talk about it conor we're all patting
you're just patting each other on the
back it's it's just unbelievable when
you look at
when you're trading for aj brown right
and that's the return it was 18 and a
very very late pick because you're
equipped what
it doesn't that doesn't make sense a guy
that's entering his prime and fits
everything you want to do he blocks his
butt off he can catch the ball down the
field he's angry runner with the ball in
his hands that alone to me made them the
winners but the way they navigated the
board to jump up and get
the
hulk right of the draft yes i mean
somebody that i literally called in the
comp a bigger vince wilfork yeah and
jordan davis and it is of all the
positions on the eagles it is the one
that they have shown over again that
they value the most they invest the most
into it and what he does for everyone
else keeping guys like hassan redick and
josh sweat a little bit more clean yeah
well i'm curious to see the usage of him
i'm very curious to see how they use him
i know kelsey referenced the idea of
using him in multiple positions i'm very
curious to watch how he's used because
that's going to be the real key to the
value of that pick for me because if he
just drafted him to sit him inside
i don't know that's not a top 15 guy
yeah i don't know that i love it but if
you're going to move him around as
kelsey alluded to then i think you've
got an opportunity i think that's going
to be a really really fun one i'm
excited to see him evolve in
philadelphia i think that's a place you
go to evolve on the defensive line like
he mentioned with jonathan gannon he's
he'll experiment with the five yeah
and all that stuff so you did take
obviously mine uh i wrote down three
that also stuck out to me uh one being
kansas city leaving with mcduffie and
carloftus addressing both yes didn't
feel as juicy though then i wrote down
the ravens and i thought kyle hamilton
and linderbaum but then i went yeah but
they also traded their quarterback's
favorite wide receivers that can't be
happy and other than the eagles i'm
giving my big winner to the detroit
lions leaving here with aiden hutchinson
and jameson williams and you're fighting
you're getting aiden hutchinson who for
a team in the lions now you really have
your face of the franchise because it
ain't jared goff so now aiden hutchinson
is your local boy that can be dan
campbell's you know prized possession
but you're also getting a jameson
williams guy that you partner up with
our dude amman ross st brown but also
whoever the next quarterback is and heck
guys they might get malik in the third
pick of this second round yeah i don't
know exactly what they had to trade did
they move it for jmo but then they have
two picks at the beginning of this round
so many moves but jameson could be the
guy for this quarterback or the next
quarterback i i love what the lions did
but i would i would be lying if i told
you
that the eagles are my big winner and
because i'm just in shock
i'll seek one more in i was gonna say i
i got two more you got you go the giants
in there for you i got the giants i love
what the giants did not i'll let felder
kind of run away with that in a second
just to get kayvon thibodeaux for your
pass rush and still get evan neal yes
exactly the giants what they've missed
for so long is a ground floor right they
kept just trying to put a roof over
nothing by paying kenny galladay a ton
of money paying a dory jackson a ton of
money just strange selections now
they're ground floor ground floor kayvon
thibodeaux can't build a house without a
foundation that's it for the giants this
was a sure maybe not the most glamorous
but it's a smart effective draft that's
gonna get you back on track in a
two-year plan yeah i love that and then
i'm gonna go listen i'm gonna go to my
roots i'm gonna go to college
georgia
georgia
every single piece of recruiting
material that they put out for the next
year is gonna have five first rounders
on it it's gonna have five guys picked
in the top five guys picked in the top
32. five first rounders they're gonna
that's what's gonna be on there they're
gonna listen i'm sure tomorrow and i'm
gonna look for it i bet the promo tweets
are already out there because they're
like look at what you wanna come you
wanna be a champion come play for the
dongs you wanna go to the nfl come play
for the dolls
yeah they're gonna go oh alabama how
many did you have oh you had two two oh
that's that's not five craziest thing i
i know how felder feels about this the
second best georgia player in this draft
in my eyes only behind jordan davis is
going to be on the board when we're back
on the clock tomorrow guys yes so can we
take a quick look at conor's big board
as we will be back tomorrow right here
on the br app and on youtube uh and
these are the best players available
according to conor's big board david
jabo is still there nakobi dean is still
there the big defensive tackle out of uh
uconn travis jones is still there emma
kitay is there um and we did not see a
running back
uh no running back and no tight end
which if i have this right has never
happened in this era like going back
like 70 years or something we took a lot
of the winners so it's okay if our guys
uh steal some too let's go to richard
sherman first richard you're your big
winner uh from this first round who
jumped out to you could be any team that
we've mentioned or haven't mentioned
or player
well i think it has to be derek stingley
i think it has to be derek singley i
think coming off of the injury coming
off a list frank injury to go number
three in the draft to be the first
corner taken
obviously tested incredibly at his pro
day i think he you got to be jumping for
joy you know there's a lot of doubt
there's a lot of uncertainty when you're
coming off the injury you only play a
few games you you had a kind of up and
down uh sophomore year
so i think he has to be feeling like
feeling great about everything you know
i know the houston texans are happy and
excited to get him he's going to be a
big time play maker for him but he's my
he's my uh winner for today let's go to
a monroe st brown he was busy early six
wide receivers taken in the first 18
picks but then we didn't hear from him
again i called your detroit lions a
winner uh who do you see as a winner
player or team
i'm gonna go with players so obviously
i'm gonna go with my guy drake london
winner for him being the first receiver
taken after having ankle surgery you
know he had seizing ending injury uh i
think it was a week eight or nine
apparently the first receiver picked is
huge for him
um you know atlanta's gonna turn things
in they got pissed mariota so i think
he'll do just fine over there and then
one more i have to go with his kyle
hamilton on the ravens i know he got
picked later than expected but for him
that defense i think fits in perfect
like we talked about earlier you guys
talked about earlier a safety in that
defense in that division the the type of
offenses that that he'll see a lot of
running a lot of running the ball in
that that division so i think he's going
to thrive in that defense and i think
that's a perfect fit for him you talk
about players going to teams and as a
player you want to go to a team with a
perfect fit so yeah i think for kyle
hamilton that was the perfect fit for
him undoubtedly so and then we will wrap
it up with jason kelsey uh who him and i
were yelling at the top of our lungs
earlier uh who do you see as the big
winners whether it's a player a team
yeah i mean i see that new york's is
both coming away with probably the
biggest uh nights for the most part on
this i mean joe douglas was extremely
active able to pull off a bunch of
really solid moves robert sal is an
incredibly defensive coordinator he's
added now a
lockdown corner and sauce gardener as
well as a premier edge defender which
will pair up nicely with some of the
other players they got up front
new york evan neal was probably my
favorite pass blocking tackle they got
two solid tackles now
uh to add to an edge defender to go
along with those two monsters inside
that they have
um
but but i'll say this what an amazing
night what an amazing night because we
got to witness a bunch of people realize
the american dream a bunch of kids
are realizing the dream of playing in
the nfl and that's why the nfl draft is
so
freaking awesome man
it's it's it's incredible
it's an incredible moon for all these
kids and all their families and all
their hometowns and everywhere they've
been
and um
but
only one team
got a certified dog in the nfl tonight
and that's the philadelphia eagles
so i don't think it's anywhere close my
man howie roseman was at work
and uh i'm ready to go to work
jason i couldn't understand the word you
were saying because i was watching porn
on this television and it was aj brown
highlights and i'm just sitting here
being like this guy is on the eagles
right now
unbelievable man
what a night what a night howie roseman
jason kelsey was fired up says kush and
cook's champ
decent kelsey was fired up man what a
great night uh
huge thank you to jason kelsey at monroe
st brown and richard sherman for joining
us thank you for their time and their
analysis
thank you to connor rogers and his big
brain and his big board big thank you to
michael felder for holding it down
we are back tomorrow night shout out to
kaplan shout out to mcmanus shout out to
to brett rosen in the back gabe everyone
here in the production making it happen
we are here tomorrow's better always
better it's where super bowls are won
bowls are one tomorrow anybody in the
seats can draft in the first round the
real dog's draft in the second and third
and win super bowls and if you really
care about the draft you'll join us if
you want to be a noob enjoy television
peace see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
you